I will be in Tampa Florida I want to let
you know that from June 23rd to 25th
this Friday Saturday Sunday this weekend
that's right
um seats are selling fast I'm thankful
for that and uh We've also added more
seats in Guilford New Hampshire on July
20th at the Bank of New Hampshire
Pavilion those are lawn seats you can
sit out on the lawn and bring something
I don't know what you can bring you got
to check with the venue but maybe get
you a little
um
tapestry or something about the
leblancet and get out there and hug
somebody and giggle y'all can lay there
together and Spoon and giggle if you
want and he'll take a damn pill or
something if you're doing pills I don't
know I don't do them
we also have tickets available in
Edmonton Alberta on July 14th Grantville
PA on July 19th Windsor Ontario on
August 18th Toronto Ontario August 19th
and Niagara Falls August 20th that's
where you get all the tickets
theovan.com
t-o-u-r thank you so much for supporting
the return of the Rat tour I want you to
check out the new Rat Life tease they're
in light blue salmon and sand and the
new Rat King big head teas hey Big Head
from Alaska to Nebraska baby you know
what I'm saying you want to tickle that
nickel I'm the Fonz with the bronze baby
all that and more at theovan store.com
love you guys
I want to thank Rooster Teeth for
allowing us uh time today here in their
Studio space
out here in Austin Texas we are grateful
uh to them and we are grateful for this
space
today's guest is a comedian uh he's a
podcaster
um he's in I think I would say he's an
enlightened being he has his own podcast
called The Duncan Trussell Family Hour
um he has a show on Netflix he's one of
a kind today's guest is my friend Mr
Duncan Trussell
hey
[Music]
you
oh wow
[Applause]
they had a man by us that uh
they found a Korean guy who had been
hiding I guess in the ceiling of the
YMCA
yeah this was in um Santa Monica
they found a Korean in the ceiling and
so they uh they shut everything down one
time like the police came in and rated
him he'd been going there for years you
know he'd been like sneaking he's like
one of those
you know people are uh
what's that new thing people are hiding
in people's homes or whatever nesting
yeah
yeah nesting yeah they nest in your
house you don't know they come down and
drink your milk right sorry yeah that's
what's going on it's like there was and
this guy was nesting
um
in the YMCA not a bad place to Nest oh
no and I would I remember I saw him for
years sorry Zach uh I was a bit of
abrupt there I'm having a long I'm
having a long day
what happened
well there's [__] people in the
ceiling brother there's people in my
ceiling right now you know there's
squatters I got Koreans in my brain I
got Brothers in my head who knows what
else yeah man it would be so wonderful
to have some brain scanning device that
showed you a visual depiction of all the
various entities whatever they may be
whether it's you know psychological
structures or authentic demons so you
could just get the rundown like when you
get blood tests you know yeah because
then you'd know you'd know like why
you're acting the way you act sometimes
not you specifically but you know when
the monster pops out oh I I think that
that's you know I wonder a lot if we do
I was just talking about this with on
Rogan the other day if we do enough of
the right testing like like we take
people's temperature like that's such a
temperature is such a who cares you can
almost guess it you know if you're just
if you're anybody with a thermometer
with it two cents you know finger yeah
like you could be you could touch
somebody like oh you're warm or you're
cold you know you're dead you're alive
you know it's like but I feel like
it we just we have such primitive
testing it still feels like that we're
allowed to see right I would love to
know yeah what's what the f who's in
here today right what skeletons are out
yeah what unaddressed trauma is about to
explode out of me in the middle of
traffic yeah and then you'll know and
then maybe it won't happen but this is
yeah I man it's you know I think
the testing we have on the human body is
pretty remarkable right like you can do
like you don't even have to get the uh
what the prostate thing you know where
they shove the tube and cut the polyps
it's disgusting it's like a haircut for
your intestines I gotta get one soon but
the you could just do like some tests
that tells you if you know you've got a
problem yeah you don't have to get
the Michael Jackson drug and then have
this long tube that your doctor is
weirdly like excited to tell you about
yeah he's listening to Billie Jean while
he puts it in you
it was so excited he's like you'll be
able to see your appendix like I don't
want to see my [__] appendix I never
want to see it I want to die without
seeing my appendix yeah but anyway now
they can just test it I can't remember
what the name of it is the worst
commercial on TV it's like a like a an
annoying corrective animation like
interrupts people when they're swimming
and it's like have you had your [__]
checked yeah it's a stupid commercial
but the point is if they can do that
it's interesting the mind the mind is
like the ocean you know we have no idea
what's going on in there like it's the
biggest part of planet Earth and we
barely know it's down there it's really
curious well in the ocean too man the
ocean a lot of it is most of the animals
are by the edge
yeah right like that you're talking like
down there in those thermal vents it
starts at low population density and
what is down there is like terrif is
terrifying well it's the same type of
people that live I think if you get out
in a very rural Utah or you get out into
like you go deep into the mountains or
into some Caverns or something you find
some real cryptic homies out there oh my
dude you know when I was in Asheville uh
the last day of my kids preschool right
before we left
I met a psychologist whose job was to go
out in the Deep Appalachia and like you
know it's that's where all his clients
were and just what you're saying like
the stuff going on out there is crazy
like he was telling me one of his
patients took a scythe
and went to this dude's trailer where I
guess he's sitting watching TV and use
the Scythe to cut through the trailer
into the suits back like
the wall with a scythe you're just
watching like American Ninja Challenge
in a scythe comes through your [__]
trailer but how interactive is that I
mean you couldn't no matter what cable
you paid for rarely would you be
watching American ninja and then an
actual
bootleg [__] meth ninja rolls up with
a scythe and cracks through your
homestead like 80 moonshine just just
filled with that kind of moonshine that
makes your eyes turn white and you can't
do it something Sparks in his brain he's
like I'm gonna do it today
and inside someone's right yeah it's a
it's it's crazy that's our minds they it
we have our back roads and we have our
dark Bowers and secret places some
people never ever even know they just
think they're like the first thing that
comes to their mind they don't know that
like there's a lot of [__] down there
yeah they don't know that there's people
pushing people to the front of the class
to say something they think that oh
that's the first thought I had but they
don't know there's all these dark arts
and the distance pushing people forward
I think my mind a lot of time is like
what's that Black Street that they burn
down or whatever Zach that was like a
holiday that was like black
it was like fancy
it was like the first black like Main
Street
uh you're talking about Black Wall
Street in Tulsa yeah that was yeah burn
it down they burned it down a long time
ago I'm not sure what exactly happened
um
it may have been racism it may have just
been fireworks I don't know what it was
white residents attack black residents
homes and business as well as close for
public institutions in Greenwood
District of Tulsa Oklahoma an oil boom
City Black Wall Street one of the
wealthiest black communities it was like
kind of your early Atlanta Jesus Christ
they burn it all down yeah the property
loss 35 blocks were systematically
loaded and burned
um
yeah I don't know does it say why they
did this
I'm guessing it's not fireworks yeah
this looks more like probably racism
mobs of white residents
the Red Cross provided relief uh do you
see any if you see something Zach let me
know won't you peep on it while we're
um
but that's what kind of my head is you
know I remember going to the doctor one
time when I was young and the guy they
put that thing in your head that little
looker you know
the looker they'd like it they put oh
the ear looker yeah stethoscope it's
called an earlooker stethoscope yeah
earlooker yeah I got it well I know yeah
stethoscope they put it in there and the
guy was like oh you got a bunch of uh
Brothers in your head right but he said
the n-word right the doctor yeah and I
remember that and I was like
and he was just joking around I guess
you know but I it was like I didn't know
what was going on how old were you I was
probably nine or ten you know just think
of that dude like imagine being that
doctor looking in a kid's ear and that
is what makes sense for you to say yeah
and that's a doctor he looked in he's
like oh you got a bunch of n words in
your head and I was like whoa what the
[__] well tell him to come out dude at
least like you know let's get on a first
name basis but it blew my mind I think
he was trying to like make my dad laugh
or something you know it was just back
in the days when it was just kind of
semi-casual racism right you know I mean
that's not even semi-casual racism
that's like I mean if we're gonna like
analyze racism that's pretty hardcore
like and that it sounds like a joke he
makes like that's just one of the funny
bedside manner things he does when he's
with nine-year-olds like that generally
cracks nine years olds up I guess it
would
oh I didn't know what was going on I
didn't know if like half of like In
Living Color was living in America you
know humans in my ear what are you
talking you're a doctor I'm gonna trust
you
whoa yeah yeah it was just kind of the
the environment around us I think at
least you remembered it man like that's
the problem is like stuff happens like
that to you when you're a kid and you
forget it and then you get this like
weird little limp like a micro limp a
weird little like you have anxiety
attacks when you see earlookers or you
you don't know why that's the problem we
forget the Mind forgets but a lot of
stuff just gets in there just gets in
dude I was
like a few months ago
I don't know man you know I've done
psychedelics my whole life so like if I
get a little wobbly generally I'm just
like all right whatever you're wobbly
today but I was like particularly like
weird like I was off I don't know how
off you get but I was like off off and
my wife was like what's going on with
you and I'm you know doing the Rolodex
if I've been eating a lot of Edibles am
I getting enough sleep you know and like
everything's pretty normal
and then I'm like [__] I Google search
because I try not to remember it when my
mom died that day no didn't remember it
didn't remember the date but my body
remembered it and like I talked to my
friend who's a psychiatrist he's like
yeah that's seasonal triggers
they like activate people's grief and
some people don't even know that's
what's happening it's so wild man that
that's just stored in us forever and
what else is in there yeah like surely
it's not just the worst thing that
happened to you it's probably lighter
shades of things that and you think
that's your personality it just triggers
yeah a lot of our personality is
basically it's the foliage that's built
upon the sediment of the things that
have happened to us as we grew yeah man
yeah you know it's really fascinating I
think um
yeah I I wonder how many two of those
things can be like triggers from
previous generations even you know yeah
I mean I think there's a lot of
Investigation into that now epigenetics
yeah and also I mean you see like a
zygote or something or what's that
beautiful rock ever bought one of those
beautiful rocks
and you crack it open and it's goddamn
magic in it it's just geodes yeah so
cool God and you're like wow this is in
there you know yeah right
yeah right it's not a horrible [__]
inside of us I mean it's that's the
that's the thing like underneath all the
all whatever the weird neurotic foliage
you have is like for a lot of people
there's there's like things like that oh
yeah and these are a lot of women that
you know that didn't have kids or
whatever end up loving these things
I didn't know that is that true yeah
these are like the Pringles for women
that couldn't
you know like uh didn't have a child I
think I did not know that man that's
cool yeah I didn't I guess I get it it's
kind of like a womb it's like this
universe in a womb or something well if
you really think about what would life
be like right if you thought about life
yeah because I'm sure if you say you saw
a little bit about a little bucket of
uterus or a bucket of uh not uterus but
what's that placenta right if you saw a
little placenta on the ground you're
like Ugh look if you didn't know it was
placenta say you're walking by you'll be
like oh my God you've seen live placenta
a hippopotamus sneezed over here no dude
when I saw placenta for the first time
when my wife gave birth
it's an alien like that is not of this
world it's the it's the craziest thing
you've ever seen and it's just they just
grow that man they can just do that it's
an organ that they grow and then and
then eject it's nuts who does it who
does what grows it well I mean I'm
assuming like it's something you know
the DNA it's like you know once you get
once you're pregnant it just sort of it
just you their body's not oh women who
did you think I said I don't know I
thought someone was growing it somewhere
Placida farmer and he invited me over
and it was just you they grow it in
aquariums lots of jizz it's basically
cheese and honey and like you know
depending like everyone has a different
recipe yeah you have a bunch of there's
a bunch of Asians beating the rice off
of it out in like little boats there's
all kinds of ways to make Placida Theo
these days especially my grandmother's
placenta recipe is insane oh yeah dude
that yeah I've had yeah yeah I've had
plus and uh it's like just depends on
the holiday oh my god when you get a
wonderful Placida it's just so it's so
great harder to find these days I don't
mean to be like an old man and complain
but when I was younger you would get
like much better placenta oh the
Christmas placenta my grandparents would
bring over
oh my God the smell of fresh placenta
bubbling on the stove
cinnamon roasting on an open fire god it
was good and my grandmother would put
cinnamon on hers are you kidding me
it's so interesting man it's so
interesting yeah so this was like a big
in my family over Christmas dinner my
grandma my grandfather was like why
don't we add cinnamon to the placenta
and like my grandmother just started
weeping and walked out of the room so
ever since then I've been afraid to try
it but I've heard it gets you super high
yeah it's a real uh I mean it's brought
families together for years I think yeah
I think it's an American tradition I
don't know why people are against it
it's just like what you can you can
adapt you can adjust yeah have you ever
read grapes or wrath dude if we that
book was a half chapter away from them
eating a bowl of boiled placenta that's
right yeah just eat it eat the placenta
eat whatever you want I mean the last
page of that book They're breastfeeding
off their own
sibling I think because they were so
starving in that book well I mean did
you hear like when they recovered Jim
Morrison's body in the bathtub in Paris
his mouth was full of placenta a lot of
people think it was heroin that killed
him but like he got high in choked on
placenta oh like Parisian placenta
which is good oh yeah or not it sounds
snobby but the I don't think anything
beats the placenta of France yeah
you sound exactly like someone serving
placenta in Paris you've done this
you've been on the placenta tours I want
to know hopeless
I was first week of my life
did you guys see that uh Morgan Wallen
is on tour
of course she did he's out there who
else is touring
um the Harlem Globetrotters I believe
are out there doing it Willie Nelson
maybe on his last tour ever
a lot of touring going on
and that's good timing for the newest
sponsor of the podcast which is seat
geek with over 28 million downloads
SeatGeek is the number one rated
ticketing app there are more than 70 000
events every single day on SeatGeek
including concert Sports festivals and
more you know I went and saw Duran Duran
the other day or double Duran some
people call them
um
and I got the tickets off seat gig yes I
did they've got tickets to Tyler
Childers Drake Beyonce everyone they put
all the tickets across the web in one
place to make sure you're getting a good
deal each ticket is rated on a scale of
one to ten so look for the green dots
green means good red means bad every
ticket is backed by their buyer
guarantee and seat geek is the only site
that lets you return your ticket ahead
of the event with swaps that's how they
do it
and you know I came through for you guys
use my code Theo for 20 off tickets at
seat geek that's right 20 off your first
purchase with promo code Theo make sure
you click the link in the description to
download the app thank you for
supporting live uh music and comedy and
anything you go see this episode is
brought to you by zip pics nicotine
toothpicks zip picks z i p p i x brings
you a totally satisfying convenient and
great tasting way to curb your nicotine
Cravings that's right if you craving it
Nick boy if you nicking out you nicking
around that's right
don't you think it's time you stop
putting smoke and vape oils in your
lungs I do
now you can get your nicotine fix
anytime anywhere without having to rely
on smoking or vaping
zipx toothpicks give you an easier
healthier and more discreet way to get
your fix baby get that hitter they're
available in six or eight flavors and
they have options in two milligrams and
three milligrams of nicotine
that's right they're perfect for flights
sporting events restaurants and
literally everywhere else that smoking
and vaping are banned zip picks also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks if you're not a nicotine user
or if you're trying to get away from
your nicotine habit
ditch the cigarettes ditch The Vape and
get some nicotine infused toothpicks at
zipx toothpicks.com today get 10 off
your first order by using the code Theo
at checkout your lungs will be glad you
did that's z-i-p-p-i-x
toothpicks
t-o-o-t-h-p-i-c-k-s.com zipx
toothpicks.com ten percent off your
first order by using Code Theo at
checkout must be 21 or older to order
zip more smoke less with zipx nicotine
toothpicks that's great dude yeah
placenta man it is uh so you saw it
though when your wife had it oh yeah you
see it yeah you you see it I mean well
you save it like these like these days
they're actually recommending that you
like save the placenta or I think it's a
placenta like the idea is like in the
placenta I could be wrong about this
maybe it's the umbilical cord they're
stem cells that theoretically in the
next 10 20 years if you have access to
your stem cells from when you were first
born you could like reverse the aging
process so lots of people who can afford
it are saving their stem cells their
placenta I can't remember there's a name
for it I think it's called cord blood
but all that stuff like they
cryogenically free freeze it and then
down the line theoretically you could
like
heal yourself you could grow your body
back oh I would use that in heartbeat I
think I would too what is that what are
we saving Zach you have any information
on that yeah cord blood is the right
word but it is people do like save and
eat the placenta
um or bury it do you want I have a
picture of a placenta if you want to see
it I would love to it's kind of strong
though
yeah okay yeah wow and is that cooked or
not cooked bring it back up that looked
like Rob Lucena that's right yeah that's
probably Chef Anthony Bourdain's kitchen
or a cooking show or something oh yeah
this looks like a little bit yeah this
ain't no Wolfgang Puck this looks like
hot this looks like real people do eat
this though you're right I've heard that
in La like women save the placenta and
literally put it in like smoothies like
that like people are they'll like
incorporate it into daily eat it well
there's a new purse too I think they're
doing it personal you know what the
purse is beautiful Gucci has a wonderful
placenta purse for the season a summer
placenta purse but the um
the pro here's what's happened that what
happens and uh it's a real problem is
that people bury their placenta and they
have a little ceremony for it but they
don't bury it deep enough and their dogs
dig it up oh so like you go you're like
sitting down to watch TV and you look
and like there's like half eaten
placenta on it
[Laughter]
I'm gonna put it in a box or bury it
deep because dogs just love placenta who
yeah I can't even it's everything yeah
it's everything a dog would want it has
blood in it it's like
from the crotch area you know it's like
dogs love all that oh my God it's so yes
it's literally a dog's dream food yeah
for sure
I uh
yeah I I do think it is kind of
fascinating though that we don't have a
bet like are we missing levels of
ourselves in basic scans and information
that like how close are we to be able to
do a scan an MRI that tells us what's
going on with ourselves at some
different levels like an emotional CAT
scan yeah emotional seems to be the
level that seems to be a lot of the
realm that we're really missing I feel
like when it comes to uh
um uh like uh diagnoses yeah for sure
yeah for sure because I mean all the
psychologist has to go on is what the
patient is telling them right that's it
you can't
you can't do anything other than that or
like past behaviors or you know but
still you don't know yeah I mean this is
to me the astounding part of being human
is
we're choosing to behave the way we do
like Ulta like you many times I would
like to think I didn't really have a
choice there like that that just was a
reaction to an event that spontaneously
erupted out of me but
if you kind of mindfully study your
worst moments most of the time you'll
realize there was like a micro moment
where you decided to like do your
defense mechanism that always hurts
people's feelings or gives you uh a
feeling later of guilt or something
there's this weird microsecondary you
decide to do it like your brain is some
kind of computer and it spit it's like
Choose Your Own Adventure and it spits
out a few options and you pick the most
annoying aggressive shitty one yes you
chose to do it it you know you weren't
possessed right but the choice happened
so quick that you could easily miss the
choice that's what's cool about it is
you don't have to be the way you are at
all change your clothes change your hair
cut get a face tattoo whatever you want
you could do whatever you want but we're
addicted to being us you know it's so
habitual
wow you know and it's one thing I
noticed with doing meditation right that
starts to help me is I'm not just
like in the carriage of the uh roller
coaster I'm on I'm not just because
usually I'm so attached to my own life
I'm like oh this is what but if I do
some meditation even for a couple weeks
yeah I'm start to have a little bit more
separation yeah from me and what I'm
doing so I'm like oh
I do have a little bit more choice I can
see a little bit more how I'm behaving
instead of just behaving like if you're
always upset if you're always anything
or if you're feel like you are just
constantly in response to some choices
that you're making and you're like [__]
I don't know what's going on meditation
has always given me a little bit of a
step back where it's like oh
I'm not always just the guy sitting in
the um in the roller coaster car about
to go on the ride now sometimes I'm the
person waiting by the side of it like
I'm the conductor a little yeah it's
like oh interesting God roller coaster
is a great way to describe it man
there's a lot of antiquated ways of
describing it uh
Chariot attached to like the most
powerful horses if you can't control
them you're gonna get dragged wild
elephant wild elephant but you know
that's a you know this is an Eastern you
have to grow up in India to even know
like what that means I mean I've seen
videos of wild elephants they're not
great yeah the roller coaster
that's [__] awesome man roller
coaster that's the new description
roller coaster it's that yeah but just
not being so attached myself I will say
that that's the only time I'm able to
get any insight into like wow look at my
behaviors look at what's going on
instead of just being my behavior yeah
yeah I mean and you know
something that's really wonderful is
if you it's not like you have that pause
that seems to expand with meditation so
you have a little more time to decide
what you're going to do
you it doesn't mean you're going to
choose the well-behaved thing to do it
just means if you do choose to be an
[__] you know you did on purpose you
thought about it and you're like I'm
gonna be a [__] [__] here I'm
deciding instead of spontaneously just
going [__] mode right that's it
that's what meditation provides it
provides you the ability or the
noticeability to go from spontaneously
being an [__] to choosing to say hey
I'm going to be an [__]
that's gonna get a gift
no you know one thing I I don't know
because I haven't read this is someone
who's friends with him told me that once
heard ramdas the spiritual teachers say
if an if an [__] gets enlightened
then they're going to be an enlightened
[__]
this whole notion that you start
meditating or take up the spiritual path
and like now like I don't know you're
making like Instagram videos in front of
like Crystal Pools of water and and
beautiful forests with your beads and
you're like emanating light that is not
the case it just you just like you're
saying you become the roller coaster
conductor at least you know that you are
simultaneously controlling the ride and
getting on the ride yes there's some
freedom in that I think
well it's interesting because then you
start to see oh well what else could be
going on in the depths of me when I'm
not just sitting here in the same like
at the beach of myself I'm not just you
know it's like I feel like that's one of
the first steps in the sort of getting
into like
realizing there's more to you than just
being this reactive
substance described as like a human
reactive
the aliens call us that's probably what
they thought it was at first they're
just like there's these Rea there's a
bunch of reactive substance on that
planet yeah I don't know what it is
sometimes it like gets into
Vehicles we think it's Vehicles yeah
yeah once sometimes a doctor tells one
of them one of them tells them when they
have black guys in their head as a child
yeah I know well you know I did like I
did read that maybe that is the reason
even though these days I guess you can't
say we're not getting visited but one of
the theories on why aliens are coming
here is because they don't consider us
intelligent life yeah so they just see
us as some just like what you're saying
some kind of like
vaguely sentient reactive meat yeah not
worth visiting I think that makes sense
I mean I've long thought the reason why
I think aliens used to come a lot
probably back in the day right they came
a lot that's why you saw a lot of
Egyptians drawing them yeah you know and
um and even the fact that they would
stay stable long enough for an Egyptian
to draw because an Egypt you know like
they had to get a candle they had to
light it they had to get the guy who
could draw like it was a little bit more
of than just yeah sometimes chiseling
yeah it was more than just us grabbing a
phone right yeah
but I think
yeah they used to come by a lot and then
they realized it's kind of boring we've
become like one of the boring theme
parks in the Galaxy so if your parents
if you're alien parents take you to the
uh Earth yeah for your graduation I bet
the other aliens like what a [__]
loser do your parents to get a [__]
nobody's been there in Forever dude how
how poor are you guys it's like a Six
Flags knockoff yes like one of those
shitty like uh shitty the theme parks
where they don't even try to clean up
the puke yeah they're just puke
splattered everywhere you'll probably
get like pickpocketed you look at the
kids controlling the roller coaster and
they're like clearly on PCP they're not
paying attention your people die you
know people die there but yeah yeah yeah
one of the guys running the rises in a
coma but they have to hide like the
governments like you have to hire more
comatose people yeah they're just like
yeah the guy's like just like has this
morphine button in his [__] start the
ride button confused crazy I mean any
theme park I mean that is really like
to me the more terrifying than the
roller coaster itself is when you look
at the person controlling the roller
coaster and then imagine like what if
that person was controlling Subways in
New York ah would you feel okay about
that but the roller coaster is probably
more dangerous totally it's like it
shouldn't even work it's it's like using
weird physics they hired a roller
coaster architect they could afford them
for a couple of weeks through some
together and then they just let like a
17 year old on like synthetic marijuana
for sure oh yeah control that [__]
thing yeah and then yeah yeah yeah and
then he spins he that kid he lobbies to
get a DJ there at the same time like for
the ride right like they're like we
could spend more money on safety and
he's like no way dude no we need my boy
Ricky right here to spin his tables on
the side that's right and you know they
know they have insurance so they're just
like look I'm paying a [__] ton of money
for roller coaster insurance if someone
gets hurt they get [__] hurt we're
getting a DJ we're covered legally
this is the rhythm of the night
I think he's having a seizure I think
the roller coaster Operator just had a
micro seizure
oh he's having a seizure dude beat up
the beat bro we got a [__] drop the
beat that'll help him dude I was in the
back of a [__] roller coaster in a [__]
theme park just like you're describing
yeah and whoever was there like
whoever's in charge of checking the the
straps comes back to me I was just a kid
man and she looks at me and she's like
you're not even supposed to be sitting
in the back the person next to you sees
heavy there's a chance you could break a
rip there wasn't I'm gonna take you out
and put you in a different seat she just
said that as she's tightening the thing
that's holding me in the car
and then it just goes and she was right
like the person next to me was smashing
it hurt like it didn't break my wrist it
should hurt man yeah it hurt it should
hurt
so what kind of meditation do you do
Theo
what I do is I wake up in the morning I
say a prayer I do a reading and then I
do 10 minutes of meditation I just close
my eyes
how to sit there and if any thoughts
come up
I try to uh let's let them pass and not
attach to him cool I set my phone timer
for 10 minutes
and that's it and then I do like a
written meditation after that where I
was right for 10 minutes straight just
whatever comes into my stream of
Consciousness yeah that's great man you
do that every day I've done that every
day man I would say or at least six days
a week I would say for probably the past
few months four months maybe wow that's
incredible it makes you feel a little
bit more like
like I'm okay to think about stuff and
not just be as reactive sometimes yeah
man I mean that's amazing that's a long
four months of like that kind of
practice is a big deal yeah it feels
pretty good man
um
but yeah I think uh I went to
well let me think about that a little
bit more but yeah I think Earth I I do
believe in just going back to the alien
thing that I think that Earth is it's
that old theme park where it's like
dude we're not driving all the way out
there there's nothing out there all the
information is these people are just
yeah trying to butt [__] and just
looking at you know and growing yard
drugs like we're not going over there
again I'm picturing the aliens
track display as that pops up is what
the analysis of planet Earth is
that's amazing they're just like yeah
that's not worth our time yeah we're not
going to burn best Bean crystals to
[__] go to that piece of [__] now it
will at some point though become hip
with alien youth to come back here and
do something because that's how
everything is right like at some point
it becomes cool to go to the uh to go
into graveyards like for you know
there's always like this 20 years where
nobody gives a [__] about graveyards
nobody mentions them blah blah blah blah
blah even on Halloween nobody's popping
in but then something flares up where
graveyards are [__] popular again you
know man my friend ran a graveyard and
it was a big problem goth's [__] on
the graves really yeah they had a
problem with Goths [__] on the graves
and peacocks wow the I guess the
peacocks I can't remember the problem
with the peacocks either there were like
aggressive or they were too loud or
something but the main problem was at
night Goths with like squirming under
the gate and just [__] on graves yeah
for some reason it's like uh that's a
bit like if you're running a graveyard
which by the way is apparently like a
very profitable business then you have
to have a plan for what to do when
people come and hump on the tombs
because there's some I don't know what
it is there's some kind of you know I
went jogging in that graveyard once and
I was so thirsty Theo and
I uh I turn on a spigot
and just drink some water and then I
realized
I'm drinking [__] graveyard this this
is Graveyard water this There's No Grave
gravy baby
you're sipping
yeah it didn't taste good either man it
s hang to it yeah that's [__] marrow
son oh God oh God you do you could sell
that though there's no way you couldn't
sell pure death filtered water crave
water grave water they already have what
is it like what's the new canned water
ever
liquid death it's like that's their
premium yes bottled at a cemetery in New
Orleans that doesn't have great
sanitation
so you are getting I don't know if
you've seen have you ever been to a [__]
Cemetery speaking of [__] theme parks
never been to a non and you smell
you can smell the death and some of the
graves like or the Crips yeah they're
hatched open a little bit or somebody's
yeah yeah people get in there people
will steal a bone I remember people oh
they love it well dude I grew up in a
neighborhood between a lot of people
would drive from like the main
thoroughfare in town and then they would
go through our neighborhood which was
pretty dumpy and go on to like kind of
wealthier areas
and we were right outside of the city
limits are the town limits I think we
lived in a town but
a lot of uh people would just throw [__]
out and once they get outside of the
city limits because there wasn't like a
um
you couldn't get a fine for it or
whatever
so a lot of uh there was a veterinarian
that would throw out all the animal [__]
in our yard like into our ditch by us
right no yeah so they'd have dead animal
carcasses out there all the time
so we were always beating each other
with [__] you know [__] uh Beach
like Bichon femurs and [__] or just
whipping each other if you got a [__]
big Labrador German Shepherd [__]
tibia that came through boy we beat the
[__] out of each other with that because
you because you for sure they're telling
the people who are euthanizing their
animals they're saying to them don't
worry we're gonna cremate these bodies
and we're gonna give you the ashes yeah
so what they have is probably just a
pile of Ash because it's probably
expensive to run a cremation service for
animals oh yeah so you're they're
sending fake Ash to the like grieving
dog owners or barbecue ass something
probably out of a pit yeah and so the
dog owners have no idea that the [__]
Vons are beating each other with their
beloved dog's spine
Whoop That Trick remember that song
so sad but it was crazy we'd have all
this so we'd be we'd also like we'd do
like paleontology or like make cool
animals and bury them and like there was
some cool stuff like that but yeah after
a while my mama gets so pissed because
the yard would always smell like dead
animals you know Christ man so we had
this abundance of like dead animal smell
which is a it's a tough smell to enjoy
your childhood in to want to play in you
know that's horrible man it was bad and
nobody cared at the city man that's what
made me hate government right out the
gate you know is like if we'd had a
little more money they would have come
and got the animals out you know it's
the beginning of a horror movie for sure
like somebody like has their like
demonic dog euthanized and it's like you
have to make sure you cremate this
[__] thing and they're like Valkyrie
made it sure there you go that Corso
cremated yeah I'll cremate that [__]
right now yeah don't worry just throw it
in the Vons yard the boys like to make
art with the bones at one little fella
yeah yeah they start calling him queer
for no reason like Jesus he's just
playing with the bones dude yeah that's
how you know for sure like that's really
crazy man I can't I I'm just trying to
picture like my childhood being
defined by the waft
of death that's dark man that's dark
how long did that go on for probably I
would say three years probably
maybe in the summer I think was the
worst because of this smell and it would
kind of happened in shifts it wouldn't
be like every day they would throw stuff
out there you know there'd be kind of a
time of the month or whatever I don't
want to make it like you know
you know whatever that's called
periodical or whatever but it'll be like
a time of the month where the guy would
just come and toss it all out there
they'd run it through and toss it out at
night I wonder why you picked your house
well they just picked along our street
okay I got you so I think because it was
just right outside of City Limits you
know and I think they probably lived in
like some of the nicer areas so they it
was kind of this pass through McGee
Street over there in Covington Louisiana
and people would just they'd throw all
kind of stuff out over there but you did
I remember this one girl had a little
collection of like the little necklace
or the dog little
things like dog parts no like little uh
medallions you know some dogs wear like
uh oh the car she was collecting jewelry
or something tags or something yeah like
some dogs wear a little jewelry I guess
if they're like [__]
you know from Florida or whatever I
don't even know why they would do it but
like but there's bedazzled cars like
like Trixie or something like fluffier
but you know buddy or whatever yeah
that's weird but she had a little
collection of those but it was weird
[__] like that in our area you know they
had a prosthetic limb Place bus and we
people were always we'd go in their
dumps or sometimes and get a [__]
extra limb out that [__] that's fine I
get that yeah but
I get that I wouldn't and I I get like
as a kid being excited in some weird way
about having like animal carcasses in a
ditch like that is interesting there's
something cool though yeah it was
interesting but it's gonna get old
that's all yeah and the waft of it was
bad that was the worst part and I think
my Mom hated that she hated you know
leaving us there and being under the
waft of those animals probably you know
because it just haunts everything well
it's the smell of death you're not
supposed to like it like it's supposed
to tell you don't go here this is a
place that you might get killed that's
why we don't like it right this is a
place where you might get eaten yeah it
smells like death here that's a bear ate
somebody so don't go there yeah so your
your DNA is telling you gotta get the
[__] out of here man things are dying
here and you just you're forced to live
there
yeah it was a it was an interesting area
man but yeah I think that's the thing
there will be a there will come a time
and maybe it's coming now because alien
seems to be the you know gaining
popularity I don't know if it's gaining
popularity or if it's gaining
um like more sightings or whatever what
is this yeah this is actually pretty
topical NASA just held like a four-hour
press conference about UFOs for the
first time and they're basically
admitting that it's a daily Occurrence
at this point UFOs they're actually
there's one thing that's happened since
this weirdly boring NASA press
conference where they did say this did
you see the thing
there there's now a whistleblower who
has come forward and said that the
United States has alien spaceship
wreckage and a congressman I can't
remember his name gave a statement to
the Press saying they were debriefed
that in fact we have alien wreckage that
that they're about to have hearings on
it so all the UFO people are yeah that's
it that we're definitely not alone thing
people are really freaking out right now
because you know this is what all the
UFO people have been saying is coming
disclosure so yeah it's that guy a
whistleblower says he handed over
classified evidence proving that a
secret government program has been
recovering spaceships and aliens for
decades
uh we're definitely not alone David
grush
says uh he's a Former Intelligence and
Military official
um
uh
representative rep Republican Dean
Phillips a representative Dean Phillips
from Minnesota uh Democrat Adam my first
reaction is probably like everybody
watching this which is wow and secondly
I'll believe it when I see it I mean
that's fair you're not supposed to
immediately believe UFO oh no you but
but what's interesting about this is
that the denial that usually happens
when things like someone says it's not
really happening in the same way and
again there was a congressman who said
we were debrief like did you ever see
that creep so like they did hearings on
uaps a while ago and then after the
hearing they debriefed the feds
Congress the Congress they debriefed
them
and they did an interview with one of
these representatives in the hallway
after he just got told whatever the [__]
they told him and he's he said you can
find on YouTube he said something along
the lines of lock your doors and windows
tonight folks that was his response like
whatever they told him
inspired him to say we should like lock
our doors like it's gonna keep an alien
out
lock your doors after classified hearing
on UFOs a Louisiana senator now we're
talking yeah man this is the same state
that couldn't keep Brothers outside of
my head when I was a kid dude I'm
telling you you could
you can watch can you are you allowed to
show YouTube videos on you there's a
clip of him doing it it's hilarious is
him right here doing it oh yeah that's
it flying objects that a couple of weeks
ago our skies were clear
and then all of a sudden we have spy
balloons and other identify unidentified
flying objects raining down on us like
confetti
that is not accurate
um
these objects have been flying over us
for years many years
we've known about those objects for many
years
we're not sure that we've known about
all of them but we've known about many
of them
except for the Chinese spa balloon we
don't know what they are
what's different about the last two
weeks is that we've started shooting
them down
but we can't find the remnants
except for the the the spy plane and
that's what I took away from the hearing
today
so I don't know if he paid attention
during the whole hearing no
confetti raining down like confetti it's
a great descriptor
um yeah that's what I don't yeah I think
but maybe I could see if there's an
alien life form you shoot it you
whatever yeah and it it dissipated part
of the way it's constructed is not to
fall down to this that would be the
first thing I would make of something
that can't leave evidence right like
exactly but like based on the stuff
that's coming out right now and you know
I love UFOs in the same way I love like
stories about magic and miracles and I
but I don't go full bore into it because
ultimately like day-to-day reality
isn't impacted like you know mundane
reality right taking care of the kids
paying the mortgage so you can get too
distracted by that stuff and spin out
but this moment in the United States
history is really fascinating in the
sense that if we go back to Roswell it
was a weather balloon that's what they
say even though there's like many
accounts of people saying that they saw
aliens there was weird wreckage that uh
seemed to be able to like you could bend
it out of shape and it would go back
into the form it was just like weird
[__] right
this gets uh denied by the government it
was wreckage weird stories about it
whatever we get Area 51 you know what I
mean like it has its own airplane that
flies people in you get a variety of
like early phase government
whistleblowers like Lazar I think is his
name Alan Lazar Bob Lazaria Bob Lazar uh
you get like uh that and then these
people get creamed in the media it's
like that's a lunatic he never worked at
area 51. this is [__] he's like a
con artist whatever but now what's
happening is instead of the denial that
generally follows the whistleblowers
admission of the US like having some
connection to aliens it's not getting
denied as much anymore and in fact this
whistleblower program they just created
makes it so anyone who signed an NDA he
was a private contractor and has been
assigned to work on alien wreckage can
now come forward and say I worked on
this [__] and they get full immunity
because that apparently was the back
door like you so there was a these
programs you could hire like I don't
know name any like Raytheon I don't know
for sure they I don't know if they have
records I'm just throwing out like right
yeah Raytheon um higher
Duracell say look we've got this ship it
crashed can you guys hang on to it try
to reverse engineer it and so now a
private contractor has collected the
wreckage has the wreckage meaning if
you're asked under oath do we have
wreckage you could say no and because we
don't a private contractor has the
wreckage that was the loophole so now
they set up this whistleblower program
and all these people like that guy are
starting to come out people who just
like worked it Hyundai or I don't know
worked it like Dodge Neon Dodge Neon and
they were like hey what can you reverse
engineer this thing that seems to be
bending the time space continuum and
they're like no but they couldn't say
anything about it because they signed
these hardcore ndas so now they're all
leaking the data so we're getting this
weird slow leak from all these people
that's painting a picture and that's a
real program that they allow now how did
that program get created The
Whistleblower program so what was
happening was
um well the biggest problem is like
people
apparently people get around these
things and everyone listening you can
look all this up it's like all it's I
I've got the documents it's documents
it's real like it's not like I'm just
it's real you can find all this stuff
but
the biggest problem is you're a Navy
pilot yeah and you see something that is
not functioning according to your
understanding not Kosher seems odd it's
going so fast it's stopping it's just
stopping like it's a cursor on a
computer screen then it's going the
opposite direction it's jamming your
radar it doesn't seem to have Windows
right so you see that and your choices
are
do I say I saw what is obviously a UFO
and if you do you could really like [__]
your career up yeah so you couldn't talk
about it the other problem is that
apparently people get too close to these
things they have there's a physiological
impact so let's imagine you got close to
one of these things and now you're sick
the VA won't pay for it right because
there are no UFOs what are you talking
about and so
inadvertently you end up creating a
situation where people won't say what
they're seeing up in the sky right which
isn't great if you're trying to defend
the sky we want to know what's out there
you want to know everything that's
flying through U.S airspace right so
yeah The Whistleblower program was I
think initially to kind of create a safe
way even a safe haven where people could
say okay this is what I saw I don't want
to endanger myself I don't want to
endanger not being able to get medical
care and things like that that's it yeah
yeah and and then
um and now it's sort of like now that
it's work working it's
you know all you need is like one person
to come forward
it's like me too for aliens just one
person than the next person to the next
person to the next person you know
that's what's happening all these people
who've kept this [__] like completely so
I'm sure bottled up imagine the people
that have molested people or something
just because they saw an alien and they
did not process it or went insane or
like you know like like uh so many
things yeah beat their spouse or just
imagine a guy he saw something in his
whole life he spent hiding things from
him like taking anything and hiding you
know like just weird there's weird ways
that people react to things that are
seem Beyond them yeah you know it eats
you alive and then add to it that
apparently these people have been
threatened with death that whoever's
running this [__] is not [__] around
they they don't want the general
populace they don't want the world to
know that this has happened because
apparently and again this is just
conjecture here
obviously from a military perspective if
you figure out how those things can fly
and you build a fleet of them you it's
like the new atom bomb like you are have
complete superiority in the sky and like
if we're you're living in the United
States right now you want us to be the
ones you want to be first you don't want
some other country who they apparently
all have this [__] to like win this race
but what about Mexico though you know
they don't have the [__] strongest
they're like no these [__]
don't that'd be incredible if all of a
sudden they have the most important
some God is coming up with the [__]
and bro it's the lowest riding UFO ever
like the UFO is only like two inches off
the ground like dog this [__] is funky
it goes it it goes too high dawg we
don't this [__] goes too [__] high
that would be so sick dude it would be
right it would be interesting like
whoever gets it is gonna be [__] cool
we should have a show where every
country brings their it brings their
latest like uh UFO aircraft that they
made amazing that would be the best show
skin care
you know a lot of females do it you see
a female in God
their skin just looks like somebody just
damn cared about it
like man is your skin what's your skin
who how much people care about your skin
well men
often can't find the right brand or
simply lack knowledge and understanding
of skin care it's really easy
you want to wash your skin you want to
put a nice a nice base on it some type
of a conditioner or uh moisturizer
and then you want to maybe throw an SPF
on there that's right that's right if
you're going to the mall and you're
going to go try and meet some ladies you
want to put something on fellas you want
to shine up a little bit nothing crazy
no Glitter nothing you know nothing
that's going to make the you know
somebody run out of a TGI Fridays and
hug you or whatever but you want to look
smooth and you want to look comfortable
and your skin wants to look nice your
skin is just bad it's your skin is the
front door of your organs man
that's right Caldera lab is the leader
in men's skin care they have high
performance Goods they do
and the regimen bundle that they offer
the Clean Slate the base layer and the
good
use our exclusive code Theo at Caldera
lab to enjoy 20 off their best products
that's
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-l-a-b.com to enjoy 20 off
their best products and I use Caldera I
like it
I like Caldera I like putting it on and
I like feeling it on my face and feeling
joyous and happy
get 20 off with our code Theo at
calderalab.com that's 20 off at
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-l-a-b.com by using Code
Theo take your health to the next level
in skin care with Caldera lab we've
reached that part of the show that
nobody ever skips and is sponsored by
Lucy nicotine that's right Lucy's
tobacco-free gum pouches and Breakers
our intelligent nicotine options for
upstanding responsible adults like
yourself
all Lucy products have three things in
common no tobacco
delicious
flavors and Powerful nicotine shipping
is always free and there's a 30-day
refund policy if you change your mind
you know I've been trying to ease off
vaping and uh Lucy's Lucy sent me a
bunch of gum and I'm looking forward to
trying that out you know they got
wonderful flavors over there with their
gum I know they got pomegranate
mint
and
mango they do them that's who does it
Lucy visit Lucy l-u-c-y Dot c-o and use
promo code Theo to get 20 off your first
order that's l-u-c-y dot c-o promo code
Theo to receive 20 off and always free
shipping that's right Lucy products are
only for adults of legal age and every
order is age verified warning this
product contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical
dude I you know it's an exciting time
man it's like whatever it is even if
it's because at this point it is
exciting it's exciting like and what are
you gonna do about it right what are you
gonna do about it all you're gonna do is
stay alive yeah hopefully
and yeah fine you can't let it affect
all this stuff affect you that much like
you have to have some tongue-in-cheek
look at all of it right she just enjoy
the fact that you get to live in a time
period in American history where the
federal government seems to no longer be
denying the thing that people have been
saying forever but here's my question
that would be what's in it for the
federal government
that they would now not deny it well I
think that's one of the most important
questions regarding this situation is
why why suddenly are they kind of slow
leaking this information like I don't I
don't know the answer to that like I
have no idea like well some things could
be I mean just off top my head is if
they want us to believe in some sort of
universal protector then that will come
along right like some things some
organization some like
insurance against aliens in a way not an
actual like you pay 40 bucks a month but
like right like as in creating some new
world or you know if there's that part
of that regime that like you know this
this one world order type of thing if
they yeah you know I'm just trying to
think of The Upside what does somebody
gain
um do we need a new enemy are they
realizing that like religion isn't
working enough on people anymore or the
fear of there's not enough fear imposed
on people at them you know I don't know
or it could just be that that's bluebeam
you're talking about blue beam that's
the big conspiracy theory that's like
essentially like there's two
possibilities the one you just said
which I guess if you're gonna do like
Occam's razor that is the most likely
one right what is Occam's razor the mo
the simplest solution is generally the
solution so uh in this case
it's more likely this is a human
operation than aliens based on our
understanding of physics and the
distance of habitable galaxies where
they have planets in the Goldilocks
region the amount of time it would take
to get here based on what we understand
about how fast you can go
probably if if you're gonna if you're
gonna bet bet it's not an alien right in
Vegas if you're betting you're probably
you should always bet that's not an
alien that's a human thing you're gonna
win most of the time right so uh that
that is one of the possibilities very
Sinister the idea being there's some uh
social control benefit related to
tricking the population of the planet
into thinking there's aliens that's
probably not the Occam's razor of it
then
I mean the other side of it is well we
live on a planet that's been being
visited by a variety of alien species
that more than likely genetically
engineered us a long time ago and like
shifted us from Proto hominids into what
we are now probably for a reason that
we're not gonna like like they like were
roombas or something I mean that's one
of the theories is they just wanted gold
so they genetically engineered us to
light gold so we Naturally Mine [__]
gold for them because we like shiny [__]
we like gold and that they use it as
some kind of fuel oh yeah have you seen
Basketball Wives dude no that the whole
show's about oh gold right they love
gold that's crazy it's like yeah what
are we even doing here right it doesn't
make sense like why do you like this
shiny stupid heavy [__] metal why are
you into that so much there's so many
other cooler Metals out there but gold
obsession is a real thing so the theory
is these anime Nike programmed us to
like gold because they need it for their
spaceships they didn't give a [__] about
us they're just like uh let's form some
gold here brilliant from that
perspective so that that to me is a far
more complex and and weird explanation
than just the military-industrial
complex has like networked with other
governments and they're like
I think they're at the point they're so
[__] dumb they're gonna believe
there's aliens and like we can
manipulate them that's what it seems
like that's what it would seem like to
me because I don't know
unless it they're they're like we're
getting to the point where so many
people are being like there's so much
evidence the more you make me think this
is not real the more I'm just thinking
you are not honest right like at a
certain point the the the residual
effect of the of the magic trick isn't
um it doesn't cause the beautiful
deception anymore it causes you to hate
the magician exactly exactly so that's
the thing that's weird Bros like you
know
why why and look I would love to see it
would I like to meet an alien
I don't know dude
what
give me a break you know just from our
few podcasts together and conversations
we had I don't I think wouldn't you like
it of course you like to meet an alien
it'd be the coolest thing ever don't you
want to know what they smell like
no one ever talks about that what do
they smell like what is the what does a
gray alien's head smell like
um yeah
is it bitter is it a stinky smell is it
fishy
oh if they're fishy dude
bro how much would the smell of aliens
depend on how much we give a [__] about
him anymore a lot
a lot huge bro if they smell anything
like a Korean pet store dude I'm [__]
gone dude close encounters with Third
Kind spoiler if you haven't seen it I'm
gonna spoil it the very end the guy
who's been building the mud mountains
happily walks into the spaceship the
beautiful musical spaceship imagine the
[__] thing closes and you catch that
first waft of deep like fish laying out
in the beach smell as you're like light
speed heading away from the planet and
that's gonna be what you smell forever
as you look out at the vastness of space
black holes all the beauty of space all
you can think about is there's just this
stink rotting eggs and [__] fish
hahaha
oh we would hate him the aliens
immediately we would hate him like these
stinky [__] smell so bad and
they refuse to like take showers they're
like no we don't do that
no we'll evaporate you before we'll take
a [__] shower no we are the advanced
intelligence you're supposed to stink
they're like no this is one of the many
things we figured out yeah if you don't
stink you haven't evolved like we go we
used to not stink and then we learned we
learned this is our purpose here to
admit foul odors dude I wonder also
the odors that we closet so much now
right like from shaving washing and all
the things that we do and using
ointments
how much of that we're like taking out
of like how much other stuff would I
gather about you if you came in with two
say 80 Days of hot smell on you 80 Days
of fresh dunking on you post Burning Man
Duncan yeah you come [__] rolling in
you've been hugging your kids you've
been with your wife you worked a couple
of long weeks right you've [__] been
on seven flights like yeah but you get
the four like I wonder how much are we
killing off like
some of that to go back to that like
scan of people like how much of that was
in our brains that we knew how to scan
that we were be able that we were create
able to gather more right like what if
we were the aliens initially I got you
and we've dumbed ourselves we've we've
killed off all of those things I got you
yeah man I got you it's like uh the the
there's this I heard of this study where
they took and I don't know how they did
this and um I'm not a scientist and
honestly when I hear about studies maybe
one out of a hundred I try to actually
read the study and then when I do try I
realize how dumb I am I'm like I don't
understand statistics but so all that
being said apparently it is studied they
found like good genetic matches for uh
women and they like based on their
genetics in this person's genetics
somehow this is like they would
theoretically make a great baby so
they take these dudes shirts
put them in Ziploc bags and they let the
women
uh just smell the shirt so the women are
like smelling like you know 10 shirts
and they're like pick the one that you
would want to go on a date with right
and so apparently all of them picked the
right genetic match based on the stink
the shirt well but the ones who didn't
so there was some weird connection to
like something about that was cutting
off what you're talking about the
ability to discern from someone's stink
it's some subliminal level what's going
on with it and yeah man it's a good
question like how much of the problems
we're having right now or just because
we don't stink enough like we're
supposed to smell you're supposed to
smell horrible all day long honest stink
good stink I would hate that world
though man I would I like not stinking
yeah I've grown accustomed to it now if
you Gateway stank me if you did some
Gateway stanking where like you
somebody stopped by this stank or you
put me in an Uber for four minutes and
like oh that guy stinks yeah and then
your next day you do me a six minute
Uber and then two days later you know I
have to stay sleep overnight at a
buddy's apartment who lives right next
door to like uh you know uh Canterbury
row or whatever what was that place I
think I always talked about Cannery Row
Cannery Row right so like if you keep
upping the stink on me where eventually
I [__] wanted something that staying
yeah you know what I'm saying I wanted
to meet a [__] by the sand and [__]
in uh Oahu it's hot you know we're in
keohi or somewhere it's nice isn't it
it's nice that the non-sterilized human
it's not like it's a terrible smell and
you know
how much of what we consider to be like
Bo is actually just all the weird [__]
they put in our food how much of it is
just our bodies desperate attempts to
vent
like Cheetos where your body's like I
gotta get this [__] out it's like you
know they're dumping Fukushima right now
they don't know what to do with the
Fukushima radioactive water and they're
dumping it in the ocean it's like that
our bodies are just trying to get the
poisons out of us like you know like
think of like when you drink a lot
that next day you smell like booze it's
so gross oh it's crazy we've had uh on
the uh when we're touring we've had tour
manager uh tour uh people come on the
tour who drink a lot and in the morning
you'll walk through like the little but
like the part where the bunks are and
the people are sleeping in there yeah
and it'll be like oh my God and you can
since I don't drink I can smell almost
what they've had sometimes it's crazy
like they've had beer they've had vodka
uh and and or when you're pissed smells
like coffee I don't know if that's a you
know that's or I don't know if you've
ever eaten so much weed
that your Bo starts smelling like weed
it happens it's just you know it happens
and I've heard now this is probably
[__] that probably isn't like Saints
like gurus people who've meditated their
whole lives who've gained Enlightenment
they smell different like they smell
sweet and perfumey like the original
smell of humans was or I look at
Filipinos what do you mean
they I mean Filipinos I couldn't name
seven Filipinos they don't smell good
really or wait you're using them as an
example of of like a bad smell no I
think they're enlightened people oh they
smell good oh I gotcha man I mean it's
probably a mark against me that I'm not
familiar with the smell of Filipinos
that's sad
I wonder if one ethnicity doesn't filter
as well as the other I'm sure we all
have so many differences
um Whitney Cummins is having a baby what
that's amazing I didn't know that that's
so cool
wow when did when did that
she I smelled it on her you smelled the
baby
you're growing life Whitney
see I bet in the old days that was
possible there's no way you couldn't
roll up on somebody and smell if they
were in a relationship if they had if
they were sad yeah if they were
if they had probably defecated recently
if they had had a birthday right
you just named everything that happened
to me today
the the the
um
but there's a think about all the things
in his female that because it's like
we don't there's a lot of stuff dude
sight gives you so many Clues bro you
ever been on a little bit of mushrooms
or something or done some Ayahuasca and
you can tell somebody's entire life
story by looking right in their eyes and
you're right dude this is why I don't do
acid in public anymore
because like you might be having a great
time but then all of a sudden for
whatever reason you literally experience
persons Consciousness like it transfers
to you you see the pain you see the
sadness the anger the bitterness the
Heartbreak and you just wanted to have
fun you wanted to go out to a bar and
drink but suddenly you're being
inundated by a person like what happened
to you yeah man
that's like Randy's dead and you're like
God is that I think this is why like
Clairvoyance you hear Clairvoyance
complain and stuff or like psychics or
whatever they don't like it they don't
want to be sensitive like that because
that's their daily experience is just
getting blasted by
people's Karma and it hurts and you
don't know what to do yeah I could
imagine I think there's also probably a
lot of lazy psychics out there
yeah for sure and they're like Ugh yeah
here comes a little bit more information
about you know Brenda you know
give it all there's no it'll open a can
of worms they're going to [__] ignore
that their grandmother is like talking
to the psychic she killed me she [__]
burned my body in hydrochloric acid
poured me in Theo Von's yard
please call the police and the second is
like I [__] that this is like Grandma
says hello yeah she loves you she loves
you she loves you she's happy you're
doing well yeah and she just wanted me
to say yes she just she thinks you have
a beautiful yard or something she like
makes it yeah that sucks man that I
don't like I don't like getting around
psychics because and also masseuses I
get creeped out by because I feel like
sometimes they'd you know masseuses are
often weirdly psychic because they're
touching bodies all day and I get
creeped out like are you detecting
something right are you sensing some
psychic blockage that I need to be
working on that you're afraid to tell me
it makes sense that they can do it some
of them can you know they have all those
Reiki healers and those people that are
really what is Reiki let's bring it up
Zachary please
have you heard of this stuff yeah
it's therapy Reiki therapy is a way of
guiding energy throughout
uh uh
guiding energy is based on the idea that
we all have an unseen life force energy
that flows through our bodies according
to the international center for Reiki
training a Reiki practitioner gently
moves her hands so it seems to be and
I've seen this as well I've only been
offered Reiki from a woman
removes her hands just above or on the
client's clothed body with the intention
of reducing stress and promoting healing
by encouraging healthy flow of energy
yeah it's like how much of a vessel are
we let me hit that record
you got it man I was feeling guilty oh
no don't do it don't re-trigger it man
don't re-trigger it Theo it's a horrible
addiction I know it is I want out I've
been thinking about getting acupuncture
like go ahead it's actually a very good
Vape
it's a nice flavor
what do you think it's not grape it is
really good man I'm sorry
it's okay this is our lives I know I
came in here and poisoned you it's a
contagion I triggered your react I
triggered you you had to have it I'm so
sorry this is the problem yeah you see
when you're in I wanted it
and also that particular one has this
weird heft to it that I like yeah it
feels sturdy or kind of like a uh Jeep
Grand Cherokee
I like a carpenter's Vape it's like a
industrial keep it on the Belt
you know energy blockage man that does
it to me yes this is like this is one I
don't want to get into Vape lecturing
anyone everyone's addicted to this [__]
right now but the I like I'm listening
to this great book I think it's called
why we meditate
it's so good uh and basically the idea
is
many people
me included
are in a hurry
rushing around and the reason we're in a
hurry is because we have this Speedy
kind of energy in our chest it's that
feeling when you're like [__] I gotta go
that thing you should have seen me when
I rolled in here I'm sorry Zach I want
to apologize again me too I was I know I
you know I was excited to do to see you
but also my [__] I'm late you're doing
this weird Speedy thing well what's
triggering that is energy that you know
anyone who out there is anxious or
feeling in a hurry or freaked out right
now you just tune into it like easily
you just feel it it's like a fast kind
of
uh buzzing sort of weird energy in your
chest generally or
um it's hard to get rid of it well that
right right well it's a block it's so
according to this book
that energy is supposed to be under your
belly button not up in your chest like
you're that your Energy's gotten all
[__] up but now it's all stuck in your
chest and so like feel like meditation
breathing exercises you the idea is over
time you sort of retrain yourself to get
that energy throughout your whole body
it's like it's not supposed to be just
here the imagine if you could spread it
out like nice peanut butter over your
entire psychic body that would be very
powerful it's just not supposed to be
right you're not supposed to be
freebasing the anxiety
laughs
yeah I feel like that's the culture
we're in now where we're free basing our
own anxiety yeah man we have boiled it
down to like just a granular powerful
Rock it's like fentanyl we've done the
same thing fentanyl did for heroin we
just figured out a way to add just hyper
accentuate our anxiety and coffee
doesn't help us in Red Bull nothing else
man it's already yawning here but I
think that was like my body saying hey
man we're trying to slow it down it
feels overwhelmed I'm sorry to cut you
off yeah you have one of the top
podcasts right now uh we've been
fortunate and I want to come on your
show too thank you I owe you that thank
you I know a few years ago we had talked
about it and I think I don't know if you
asked me or not and then I think the
pandemic happened and I think I said
that I was I was there was a time where
I was going through a space where I
could barely even talk to people oh my
God so um but let's get that done here
and if I don't know if you can do it
over Zoom if not I'll Zoom it's all
mine's easy it's all remote you don't
have to be anywhere at your convenience
you're busy man you're touring all the
time but I want to do it soon I want to
do it in the next month or two so that
we can uh I want to bury that that's
been a little bit of a hatchet for me in
my life and I know I brought it up I
well I said I wanted to do it and never
did it thank you Theo apology accepted
it's it's so fun just to spend time
that's what I'm realizing I'm like I'm
realizing I'm missing out sometimes on
uh getting to spend time with people
because I get so caught up in my own
responsibilities well podcasts are
friendship dates did you know that
that's what it is it's a date for
friendship you realize that the other
day I realized I went to do Rogan and I
knew I was gonna
be in town for a bit but he's so busy I
mean his like I can't even imagine how
big how just busier responsibilities he
has he's also a father you're a father
like so I realized man I should have
used that time with him on the show to
be our friendship time and sometimes I
think of those times more as like
um I do think of it as far but I could
have brought him more like questions I
have about things where like I could
have used some guidance or some
suggestions or yeah um sometimes I I
don't know why I sometimes don't do that
you know and I think with Joe we're
still getting to know each other some
yeah and his is such a big show I think
you are nervous as well but
um you know that is like the abyss of
that show is the moment you start
thinking about how many people watch it
it's scary if you let your mind go there
man that is a I really try not to do
that like before I do it it's so easy to
like think about that and then you're
like Jesus [__] Christ this is like
the top podcast
yeah Earth but yours is like the second
I saw we were scrolling through
something I don't know what it was but I
mean [__] we've been real fortunate man
you know we've been real fortunate well
you're funny too I mean it's also you're
super funny I see your stuff pop up on
my my wife makes fun of me because I do
Instagram reels instead of tick tock and
she thinks that's an old man thing to do
oh really but your stuff pops up a lot
it's very it's like I love watching it
like it always makes me laugh
yeah we got all kinds of neat stuff out
there well I think also you're such a
unique thinker man I think that um
that we need we're gonna need you more
and more in the future are you feeling
that that you whatever gifts you were
kind of given like because I know in the
beginning you were basically really just
a comedian right yeah was that your
original goal dude I wish I could say I
had an original goal that's my problem
it's so malleable malleable chaotic and
also I really try as much as possible
not out of some not spiritual High Road
in here but
I man I try to stay in the present
moment not because of
this is where you should be to find
peace but because man when I go too far
up here or I go into the future or I go
into the past I just freak the [__] out
yeah but if I'm like here in the moment
and just letting like the moment happen
it's so wonderful and so and then when I
start thinking like what the [__] am I
am my podcasts are a comedian and am I a
voice actor what the [__] am I I freak
out because it's like I have no idea
yeah so it just seems easier to be like
all right let's just grow with the
punches and be who I am yeah right and
hope for the [__] best right because
that's all you can really do I mean
honestly like looking at the world right
now
as it is
it's like come on like are we really
gonna have a next week right you think
we're gonna have a next month I don't
know I mean there's aliens on the front
porch yes there's [__] people are
fighting we don't even know who's really
behind the fighting there's like old war
debts and like ious from companies that
are like from Black Rock and Slumber J
that probably still are Milling around
in the distance of invoices being sent
to countries and people have died in
wars that we don't even know if they
were given the right reason they were
fighting for Oh you mean the the the
this is the crazy thing about the Russia
thing man these These are conscripts
like everyone's self-conscript it means
that you are drafted and and uh the the
real problem with all the people
celebrating the death of of Russian
soldiers like like their [__] blow up
dolls is that you I get not liking a a
dictator Putin and [__] invaded
Ukraine [__] you but you can't forget
and this is the Paradox a lot of those
people on the front lines getting blown
up by drones were political prisoners
right they got forced to go fight in a
goddamn meat grinder by the dude who
arrested them because they tried to get
him out of office wow imagine that you
know what I mean man it's really sad
it's like these are really well I mean I
don't know who's in jail in Russia yeah
I imagine there's some really scary
people in Russian jails who did horrible
things but I know for sure a lot of
people in Russian jails or people who
just protested like the government yeah
and those are the ones who are on the
front [__] lines so it's like you
can't really celebrate the fact that
some majority or some some percentage of
them are like were actually activists
some percentage of them were just trying
to make a more democracy happen in
Russia yeah and they got arrested so
yeah man exactly world war three other
by the way I'm not trying to get all
negative here no we're just looking at
the landscape of things I think most
people are thinking that but but here
right now hanging out with you talking
telling stories and for most people you
know this moment is so beautiful yeah
look how beautiful even like in a
podcast Studio where there's like
cameras and lights just like how cool it
is just to exist there's color and oh
yeah existing is great man you have to
and you have to remember that that hey
at least I get to be here for whatever
this is yeah at least nature gave me and
like I've gotten to come to the edge of
the Fishbowl for a moment and whatever
the existence of the universe is and how
open eyes and see something like yeah
you know what I'm saying like it's all
gonna [__] disappear so it's like the
fact that we're even getting to see a
little bit of it or have feelings like
love or
um
jerking off or hugging somebody or
eating some salmon or something you're
having some you know you're getting have
some unique moments or having a child
and hugging your child getting your
child to um you know a chocolate or
something you know it's nice it's the
best and and that like the thing I've
realized lately is the amount of anxiety
or worry that I'm experiencing in the
present moment if I let myself worry
about some future catastrophe is
actually worse than if the catastrophe
happens yeah you have you know what I'm
talking about like totally like you
imagine the thing you're most afraid of
happening whatever it may be and then
think about how bad you feel as you
worry over it versus the day after that
rotten thing happens so it's like you're
worse off and it hasn't even happened
than if it did happen yeah you're
already suffering yes an outcome that
you don't even know if it's real or not
and nine out of ten times it's not as
bad not as bad not out of 10 times
whatever it is I mean obviously there's
a few things that are going to be worse
than feeling anxious getting like slowly
eaten by a bear yeah that's gonna be
worse than like whatever your emotional
state is but most things
pretty cool and I'm probably deaf too I
imagine I imagine death is like the
ultimate version of like [__] I spent my
whole life worrying about this right
this is real chill this is great yeah
it's probably going through one of those
Turn Style things like it's a little
wonky at first and you bump into it
you're like oh this thing doesn't even
[__] open do I have the right thing
and then it opens you're like oh oh
right here we are here we are again this
is where I always come and it's
beautiful in my every single day I was
like trying to protect myself from this
this
uh you know what I'll do it again then
you reincarnate again and eventually
maybe you figure it out do you think
everybody gets drafted for reincarnation
I don't think so what do you mean
um do you think God redressed as
everybody get drafted for reincarnation
you like apparent like the model I like
for reincarnation
is that it is uh
that you don't have to
but you probably will and that you've
been doing it forever like the amount of
time if you're a human you've been
incarnating
so many times it's impossible to even
imagine how long you've been reappearing
I don't know some people are brand new
humans though you ever get that fresh
out the box [__] like yeah this
is
your first lap on this Pony homie
you know
he's like trying to get on the horse
he's like I don't know what to do you
know I've been a bumblebee for the last
6 000 incarnations you want me to
suddenly be a [__] human drive a car
yeah man yeah I I think it's possible
he's just [__] driving Uber and just
hand eating hand-eating honey out of a
jar the whole time I was a fly I was a
slug and I'm a human now that's it
that's the question have patience those
people have a little sign on who says
look this is the last seven things I was
so cut me a little bit of slack here
like damn this guy was a daddy long legs
four times in a row I was a bacteria and
now he's Luka donkey
Jesus Christ man
yeah you're right it's like it's
[__] it's like there's all these old
souls floating around like acting like
this human thing is easy flowing with
every moment
making it it's like no [__] you you're
like the guy at the gym you're like the
guy at the gym with a six-pack and the
perfect [__] body who's been working
out their whole life and that belt and
he has the weight just hanging off the
belt the whole time he's at the gym what
is that what is that that's crazy it's
crazy yeah I mean I think this is what I
love even if it's not real reincarnation
is a method for self for being
compassionate to yourself because it's
like you don't know what you were in
your last lifetime you want to talk
about epigenetics affecting current
behavior patterns according to these
ideas your past lives and decisions
you've made in your past lives are
flowering right now and at the present
moment so when you're beating yourself
up you know about this or that it could
be that really you're experiencing is
karma from the time you thought it would
be funny to grab the baby out of the
baby carriage and throw it in front of a
truck or something in the early 40s yeah
you know what I mean you don't know what
the the the bad luck you're experiencing
is necessarily originating from right
this could be yeah this could be some
guy a previous life you're you're paying
the debts of a previous existence
exactly so just take it easy on yourself
take it easy on yourself because it's
who knows well it's hard to stomach and
I think though that if we live still in
tribal communities and stuff and there
was a lot more connectivity between past
lives and we honored like who had died
previously and this and that and we were
still connected to them I think then you
would have more like compassion from
your group like oh what you're dealing
with now is what grandfather so and so
did and you know it's still making its
way out of the uh yes out of the DNA
back into nature
um
yeah Whitney's having that baby man
congratulations Mazel Tov Whitney that's
great that's great it's so cool it's the
best do you guys ever date you on
Whitney no yeah me neither do
you want it
I I think maybe you know I wouldn't mind
maybe a date or something probably yeah
of course
I think there's something that happens
as you get older if you don't have a
family when women start to get knocked
up or when people start to sparse off my
best friend Scott just got engaged or
you start thinking like oh oh [__] I
know what you're talking about you're
experiencing a version of what we're all
going to experience in our 70s my
meditation teachers teacher children
said to him when you get old
your friends start dying like flies just
dying so now what you're experiencing is
like pre-death they're going into a new
life they're being reincarnated as a
parent and you know no matter what
they're saying no matter how much
comfort they may or may not be offering
you regarding their presence in your
life you know
it's just not they're they're gonna
blink out of your reality for a little
bit it's going to change it's gonna
change it has to there everything shifts
everything and you they're just like no
way around that I mean kids are a it's a
full-time experience you you want to
hang out yeah and you know what we
experienced the the Breeders we
experience
our friends eventually being like not
asking us if we want to go get a drink
anymore because they know because every
time they ask like [__] gotta get a
babysitter oh I can't I'm doing this or
that and then so it sucks at that level
man I mean it takes extra discipline
I'm sorry man you know what you maybe
it's time yeah to start seeking your uh
life partner I think some of that is
true too you know I think I had well
when I went to and I did Ayahuasca I
think it was probably maybe a year ago
right and so that was the first time
that I started having experience with
like the younger me like the child me
you know and realizing that I just had
never wanted to grow up because I never
got to be the child I wanted to be right
I I had this and I'm not like having
self-pity I'm not trying to just like
but there was a lot of I think I had
held a huge grudge against
the world and then of just life the way
things that played out that I hadn't
gotten to have the childhood I wanted
you know right or and there wasn't
enough lessons in it that helped me to
easily adapt into the world and so I uh
but I didn't realize that until
Ayahuasca because then you're right
there with your younger self you know
yeah and that was pretty crazy you'd be
like oh wow
um you know it's time for me to
be an apparent somebody at someone has
to be a parent to this child inside of
me otherwise I'll just forever be this
child inside of me so if I want to have
a an adult life as well
then I'm gonna have to start to evolve
some you know yeah and some of that's
kind of sad because you're letting
you're basically watching this child
like
you know you're helping this child grow
up but you're letting this child know
like hey
you know I'll take it from here I love
you I'm gonna take care of you
um you're not gonna be able to run the
show all the time anymore because we got
to grow up you know yeah yeah and you
know it's being a parent you go through
these little micro griefs because you
know it starts off
you were so in love with this baby
you're so in love with like how like
just what it feels like to hold your kid
but they obviously they grow yeah and
that baby goes away it's gone and you
there's there's a period really [__]
this is so sad this like beautiful like
kid is gonna like like change into
something else but then the next
phase you realize oh I love what this
being is becoming and and so that but
that moment that weird liminal moment
between like like lives because you know
I think people reincarnate in a lifetime
like what you're talking about it is a
weird form of it's not obviously it's
not physical death yeah but it is you're
letting go of some of something oh it
feels like that a lot yeah man it really
does I can feel it I can there's moments
I have where I can feel it and I can
feel myself doing certain things that
are like okay I'm gonna put this child
to bet you know put this young not let
this you know
this child is going to start to grow up
you know he has to it's been too long if
he wants to have a family of his own if
he wants to be a father and be these
things he's going to have to dude you'd
be a great dad Thanks do you know the
gift of having a sort of tumultuous
childhood is that you uh you when you
have a kid
like I mean you get to fix that a little
bit like you you won't fix it completely
like it's so crazy
when like aspects of your parents that
maybe weren't the most evolved bubble
out of you oh yeah and you realize [__]
[__] this is why my parents were acting
the way they were acting they probably
tried to stop this thing too it's very
hard but you you have a real reason to
evolve because you don't want to like
impact your kids in a dark way so man
I'm telling you from a like spiritual
like it's a it's a brain scan man like
you will understand so much more about
your parents mainly how much they loved
you hmm you mainly you'll understand
holy [__] they love me so much there's
no way you can't feel this fear kid and
they tried their best yeah they tried
their [__] best and they in in that's
a really wild thing is then you have to
forgive them like if you were carrying a
chip on your shoulder about this or that
it'll the chip will dissolve a little
bit but I got a [__] 12 pack of
Pringles on my back and I've carried
them I've carried them I think that's a
lot of Pringles man yeah
I've carried him a lot I've tried to get
I've tried you know I do 12 step I'm
trying to get through some of it I just
have to work a little bit harder and
some of it takes time too
you know I've always been a slow evolver
I've been a really hard decider in my
life everything's really slow so yeah
man some of it's just who I am you know
slow is good
fast is suspicious
slow means you like when you do slow
change that's real change fast change
whenever I do Fast Change Makes You
nervous that's like month long you know
it'll last for a month when I do a fast
you know whatever the [__] thing is
and you should be suspicious of anyone
pitching Fast Change to you yeah it
doesn't really work like that it's slow
and it's supposed to be and you don't
need anything other than the way you are
right now man like that's just fine like
this is fine like the I'll tell you
when I met my work
like I'd heard all these cheesy [__]
who got married on kids say I knew she
was we're gonna get married
I knew we were gonna have kids and I was
like okay
whatever that's such horseshit yeah
and then it happened to me it was it
wasn't like like what happened you just
started talking to him what happened let
me hit that Ripper one more you got it
man what happened was the best it's like
you know this it's like you watch people
who put their foot in fast moving water
and it's just like they're gone
it's like that you know like the the the
the the concept of control when it comes
to
like dating and finding someone that you
decide to like spend your life with
I think it's a little naive like I think
there's big big gears in the universe
that we can't see like behind the watch
face that are just turning and I know
this sounds so new agey and cheesy but
sometimes I think it's like you meet the
person at just the right time because
the souls of your kids
are ready to come into the universe at
that time that makes sense like you know
what I mean like right now your kids
could be like in their 70s or 60s right
now in a previous life about to expire
in a few years and they're ready to pop
back in yeah and that's when you meet
the the person who they've they choose
you
and then they bring you together and
then you you are like that's when it
happens yeah I just I mean again
obviously this is probably just
horseshit but I when you're like
when it happens you realize like I don't
know how much of this I had control over
I don't know how much I chose this and
how much I was chosen for it and so that
that means go slow yeah
yeah no that's a really good that's
really nice to think on it's really nice
to just kind of yeah because it takes
some of the pressure off of you like I
don't feel a pressure to meet somebody
now I do feel like I try to be a little
bit more
like open about dating or trying to at
least meet with somebody to see if
they're that person or if there's a
possibility you know like
um
but it's been it's definitely
it's been interesting yeah but I like
that that you know the next phase is
supposed to come into the universe and
then what that what is that going to be
like and how are you just part of the
stepping stone for yeah the next part of
life because in a way that's really all
you are like we have a ton of thoughts
about
like if you just saw two animals go hump
in the woods somewhere and then two
months later they had a child you'd be
like oh it seems but if they were like
pining around if you followed one of the
animals for like four years before and
he's just like [__] rubbing his
weiner up against a bush and bugging you
know like coming on you know just
[__] chasing like you know other
animals and [__] and you're like and
watching all his thoughts he's like
sleeping in the woods and [__]
drinking dirty water to get [__] up
and stuff he'd be like God getting dumb
tattoos yeah yeah he rolls up like yeah
if animals are like us and they [__]
rolled up all these dumb tattoos if I
can CrossFit memberships and [__] and
he's [__]
holy [__] man like yeah old exercise
video DVDs in their nest
s like God animal take it easy on
yourself man one of these days nature is
just gonna send the right lioness along
and it'll all make sense you know yeah
exactly like think of like what got you
to where you're at now and then when you
really look at it like obviously you
made a choice to work hard I think that
is something we have control over I
chose work you chose to work hard but
then if you look at all the
okay all the people who helped you and
all the people you met and all The
Inspirations you got around a corner you
didn't expect to turn down and all those
things at some point you have to be like
I I don't know how much of this I'm
responsible for 100 other than working
hard so if that's the case
for for everything good in a person's
life it's gonna be the same for meeting
you know the a person that you are going
to be with in a serious way you know
like in a marriage situation because I
think you rush the [__] or you
um or or more importantly
you
pretend you're having the feeling that
this is the person you'll spend forever
with versus really having the feeling
because there's night and day difference
between the two you get into trouble you
can't pretend you have to listen because
you know
you've I mean it's nuts man like you you
just knew huh man it was the weirdest
it was so
and were we all at a park or something
where are we all at
where you saw your lady at oh yeah I was
doing a um uh a comedy show and she was
friends with my friend and
um yeah she just come there because like
you like yeah she's hanging out and then
we were hanging out and then it was like
it's weird it was weird man it was just
like
Fusion or something I can't explain it I
mean this is not to say it was perfect
no it's not to say like credits roll
movie like happy you know romantic movie
score I mean I don't think any marriage
could possibly be like that but it was
just I don't know how to explain it
other than it's like oh yeah we are
already married in some weird way it's
like if it's like Rippling backwards
through time who knows maybe it's
pheromones you know what I'm you know
maybe the materials are right and it's
just like her enough of the stink was on
my stink and her stink was a good like
combination of stinks yeah you know
maybe but I don't know I feel like it
was something bigger than that I think
it will be for you too it will be and
then you'll be like holy [__]
wow I'm [__] married I have kids
I've abandoned all that freedom
what have I done yeah
look some of that makes sense yeah well
the [__] the snake has to shed his skin
or the snake dies
that's what I start to feel too I
remember a few years ago I was sitting
in uh I was doing an episode of King in
the sting podcast because I usually work
on there with Brennan Schaub and Krista
Lee and
and Eric Griffin I don't know if Chris
is on there yet but I remember thinking
like I'm talking about timing like do we
evolve like when do we evolve
you know like when do
are there times in our lives as humans
where we are like
I was almost asking the world I feel
like when I think back on that moment
because I was surprised that I was
thinking about it or asking about it but
I was like when do we evolve when do I
evolve and I didn't know what it meant
really and I still don't exactly but
I think I was looking to evolve at that
point and I think a lot of that was
probably from that Ayahuasca experience
right that stuff's so powerful you know
have you been through it not yet I'm a
little afraid I mean I've I've you know
I've smoked DMT like everybody else so
I've experienced like some taste of what
it must be but a four hour three hour
DMT trip just sounds completely
life-altering like and I know many
people who have benefited massively from
it uh so I will eventually do it but
yeah I mean dude you here's one idea
you don't need to evolve actually the
evolution is just
realizing where you're at right now is
perfect that's the evolution it's
letting go of the fantasy of some future
better version of you and loving
yourself right now instead of crucifying
yourself on what you should be or could
be this is perfect not just like the
nice parts of you the whole spectrum is
great and that if you can really like
just let yourself play around with that
you do you take a vacation from
self-hate or whatever though or for most
people it's not self-hate though that
term gets thrown around a lot it's more
like
self like tiny micro aggressions against
oneself tiny moments where you like
judge yourself as being you know somehow
unevolved or not enough not enough or
broken or whatever yeah and and then you
know what happens for a lot of people
doing that they get hit by a [__] car
crossing the street they never evolved
they died their last thought was hating
themselves or I didn't order a bus yes
dude so like this is the to me that's
the anytime I'm not able to do I'm very
neurotic and uh quite often I will like
get down on myself but anytime I'm able
especially in the midst of like really
bad times to not resist
that to just like this is what's
happening I'm part of the universe and
right now I [__] stink and I'm tired
and I'm annoyed and I was just an
[__] to the guy putting doorknobs on
the door in my house but this is where
I'm at right now this is it yeah somehow
that's where the aggression that causes
all the things we wish we didn't do
dissipates and then suddenly just the
universe again you're just part of the
web of everythingness and it's really a
delight yeah yeah
yeah I know there are moments like that
I had a couple moments this morning I
just hit my knees I was like God I just
I can't do anything right nothing is you
know just
let me just be a part of the world let
me just realize none of this matters I'm
not going to there's nothing I'm gonna
do today that's going to change the
[__] world there's nothing I'm going
to do today that's going to alter my
life in some huge way let me just try
and be palatable to other people today
dude I love it that and I think that is
a noble aspiration and I think that that
is a wonderful everyone dude I know
because I'm guilty of it man I like I
instantaneously want to be better when
I'm sick I want to be better tomorrow
when I'm like when I'm too fat I want to
lose the [__] weight tomorrow yeah I
don't want the slow boil I want to
instantaneously change and the whole
universe doesn't work like that nothing
works like that except bad things you
can like instantaneously make yourself
worse yeah like 9 11. yes but the good
stuff it's
like it's like the the comparison gets
made to
one way to think of your life is like
Rising Sun versus Setting Sun
and like look at the way the sun rises
it is so for such an incredibly powerful
event it's so weirdly slow like the way
the light gradually changes that's
anyone's life and that's that's why it's
like [__] man a temporary Cloud passes
in front of the sunrise and it might
seem like it's becoming night again but
that's just a it's a cloud yeah you know
it's getting the sun's Rising you know
what's happening and you just start
trusting that and then at least for me
you know I become less it's just a
paradoxical because somehow by not
attempting to elevate myself to some
super egoic spiritual position I've I've
that's where happiness seems to appear
yeah just trust in the sun just trusting
the speed of the sun you know yeah trust
in the speed of the sun it's been there
for a long time it knows what it's doing
I think it knows what it's doing yeah
yeah at this point let's rely on a few
things that know what they're doing you
know yeah you can trust the sun I mean
maybe not this they were getting
apparently we're getting blasted by
solar flares not to [__] up whatever
spiritual Apex we just hit
it's we're getting blasted by like I
don't know class 50 flares they're like
the internet's gonna go down but bring
them on man in general you can trust the
sun yeah in general yeah yeah this is a
general hypothesis
um
yeah you know I think it's been
interesting I've been dealing with my
own ego too in the past year that's been
interesting you know as life gets busier
yeah and as uh my ego is very scary to
me you know the ego is very scary I feel
like how do you describe your ego what's
your just like moments where I noticed
that I think I'm deserving of things or
I expect things and I can't tell if some
of it's just because I'm busier and so
you need things to kind of fun you know
you get used to some but it's like I
want to be able to show up in like my
best way all the time you know and so so
then it takes more work to kind of like
cultivate and nurture that best way of
yourself right
um
and just kind of rolling with the you
know it's like uh so yeah I think the
ego really scares me because you don't
know what it is you know it's the ego is
always there yeah it's like your Shadow
it's always connected to you
and it can
it's such a trickster you know and you
can
it can uh make you feel deservant of
things it can make you feel
um
smarter than P you know it's like you I
just have to be care I just I'm it's
just something that's been kind of like
on my mind I think
it's so is the source of embarrassment
because it's just like oh my dude
what the [__] Theo wants me to do his
podcast again what the [__] why won't he
do mine well he must hate me does he
secretly hate me I wonder if Theo Von
secretly hates me that's you just told
me you're in a bad spot not once was my
ego compassionate not once was like he's
probably got a lot going on he's
probably not feeling who knows what it
is there's many times you have like
[__] up sending an email or or like
been in a rotten depressed state and
have not wanted to talk to anybody no it
didn't cross my egos mind yeah my ego
Puffs out gets butt hurt limps around
it's like
it's so embarrassing it's so
embarrassing but
to react to the ego
in the negative to then go to war with
that poor part of yourself that poor sad
ape in a cave
Part of Yourself
disabled veteran [__] [__] you know
uh ship captain of a ver of nobody else
on the ship poor [__]
[__] it's been trying to protect you
your whole life and it's exhausted when
you were a kid you developed it because
you needed it to keep you safe and now
it's so tired it doesn't make as much
sense anymore it's like I guess that's
dangerous [__] that guy we gotta punish
that person I think I don't know
yeah yeah you know so some combat like
I'm not don't succumb to the poor thing
but when you realize that's been one of
your number one Shield bearers I know
for the entirety of your life and then
suddenly everyone's like I'm gonna take
enough acid to evaporate you
[__] that's crazy what I've been
I've been protecting you you yeah I'm
just gonna euthanize you your teeth are
falling out [__] you it's so sad dude I
wonder if we didn't beat him if our ego
walked in the room if we'd be in what it
would look like bro that would be such a
crazy game show what if
what if we're able to get to a point one
time in existence where our e where
people have to show your ego it's like
move that bus who is that dude that used
to do that
move that bus let me hit that dude I
would never Ty Pennington yeah Ty
Pennington dude you should be moved and
people were like show you're ego and
then it's just some [__] like maybe
like a a [__] comes out playing like a
[__] trumpet you know and he's got a
bunch of [__] with him like oh damn he
goes [__] everybody's ego would have
a much bigger dick
like everybody's ego whatever
[Laughter]
my bald spot would be gone I would have
embarrassing flowing locks I think I
might have a gold chain like I think
there'll be gold chains and there would
definitely be spandex involved
maybe like a fashion cane yeah and
somebody carrying a microwave for you
that just makes unlimited pancakes
coming out of it yeah yeah there would
have to be yeah your ego would like you
would also have to present your ego's
imaginary Entourage like all the people
your ego fantasizes being surrounded by
one of mine would be Chyna that wrestler
that died a long time ago [__] yeah I
know I would want yeah I would
definitely want uh somehow I don't know
why I'd want like Stephen I lost Steven
Steven Spielberg Stephen King Stephen
Hawking and you know I would want to be
surrounded on one side by all like these
incredible creators I respect who
like were coming to me for inspiration
and then on the other side just an ocean
of beautiful women like weeping for me
there would be a cult sort of thing
happening for my egos Celine Dion's
there maybe some Celine Dion some yeah
Dion Sanders maybe Dion Celine Dion
Sanders dude
I know
oh my God you know what that's a you
know I think you could animate that show
actually I think there is a way you
could like act you could do that show
without having to have some futuristic
technology but people would have to be
completely honest with you and not
afraid to and I think it would be good
for the world oh yeah when all of a
sudden everyone Witnesses oh [__]
everyone's got the same thing I have
riding around in the roller coaster
that'd be good it's good for people it'd
be good yeah I think it would be
interesting if there were game shows
that were more bearing of our souls you
know in ways yeah um maybe that will
come as we get more technology that it
tells us more about what's going on like
that's the plane we're missing a lot of
times with a lot of like uh medical
Intuition or Discovery through like MRIs
and like
it's like I wish there was another type
of MRI like we were saying in the
beginning that could
evaluate where we are what lap is our
soul on what are we you know so then
it's like when you met somebody like oh
I see what's going on here it's like you
better get some Intel this guy's on his
6 000th lap this dude was an Egyptian
for [__] 2 000 years or this dude is
his first run ever and he's based out of
Minnesota yeah you know yeah this
[__] [__] is Hitler and now he's
like driving an Amazon delivery truck
so let's just get him what he needs okay
you're a great artist no really you're
an incredible artist
I love your art please don't do another
Holocaust
dude I'll buy the painting it's great
whatever you want nfts oh he's making an
ft's buy the [__] nfts just buy them
it doesn't matter
dude it's crazy well when our body
starts to did you see that video you see
that Tito Ortiz can you pull that out
there was a Tito Ortiz video where he
hit Mach 7 or 8. whoa and it shows you
I think it made me think about wow what
goes on inside of us and what a shell
our body is
yeah man
yeah man it's so wild it's the there's a
whole ecosystem happening in there a
whole psychic ecosystem I know and
there's like turtles in there's
everything dude a turtle swim up on the
beach the other day in Maui and uh I
went to a vacation and a turtle was
there
and uh it was just Fascinating People
like going up and seeing it and spending
time by it they're so mystical the the
Hawaiian Turtles are like holy creatures
you feel lucky to be around them they're
just they're so beautiful you ever go
scuba diving
um no
you see him in the water I mean when you
see him on Shore obviously that's like
not their best on Shore they're kind of
clumsy slow but in the water holy [__]
they're just
you know they seem like they would Grant
a wish or something yeah they're
beautiful well it makes sense then I and
that's one thing
what is this thank you friend this is
Tito Ortiz yeah passes out he hit nine
G's who is I'm so sorry priorities is a
UFC who's a UFC wrestler he is a
um he's also he does one thing that's
really neat about him he does all of the
uh
uh meals at the Laugh Factory he goes
there and passes out food that's cool on
Thanksgiving
um he's a philanthropic dude that's cool
um and he's a famous uh UFC fighter can
we go back and yeah let's see that video
but watch what happens it's interesting
to see what happens to the Shell of us
at certain uh levels yeah
acceleration equivalent to a Max
performance turning and fighter aircraft
this is one where you might pass out
all right how you doing
all right
don't do anything you don't want to do
so let me know if you don't know
profile
Alex is saying that you have to do it
okay but uh earlier call uh
yeah
it's clear
here we go oh [__] that wow he's in
there
there's a 9g simulator
holy [__]
wow
wow go back to that moment where his
face is limp it's kind of fascinating
just to see what your uh and just pause
it right there if you can find it Zach
on that screen
um
oh my God that's I mean right there I
was like wow we are just our bot it's
just a such a shell I mean here's a one
of the toughest men you know how old are
you I'm 43. I'm 48 man that is what I
look like when I wake up
shock to get the things to work again
yeah that's crazy that that's yeah the
mask is just sort of drooping off the
skull the eyes yeah man that's that's
[__] and that's almost a way of
looking at your e no that's a that's a
ego uh deflating moment to have this
moment just be out there for him that's
pretty cool just like this is if you let
my body just if let me let me show you
what it is that it's on
uh
refined form you know this is you know
Rogan talks about like this is like the
benefit of martial arts or like you know
because you're you you're you're
getting beaten up like I don't know much
about him I'm guessing in front of the
planet he's been knocked out maybe or
defeated I don't know and once that
happens
to you that you know whatever it is the
insecurity and stuff you already got you
know you you know that you are not
perfect You Know You're Gonna Lose
fights you know the way you got good at
fighting is not by winning every fight
and so apparently there's like a benefit
to that you know to to knowing where
you're at you know that's why he does
stuff like that that's putting a lot all
you know man anytime you get around like
anytime I've been around Rogan and we
get to be around like a famous fighter
they are weirdly similar to people at
the romnas Retreats really they've got
this glow to them I mean again I'm
making a blanket assessment for a few
people I've met no no oh yeah there's
something fascinating about them it's
almost like seeing some of them it's
like being around one of those Turtles
kind of yes they have this holy quality
to them or the spiritual component and
and they you would almost forget the
person you're sitting next to if for
whatever reason they decided to they
would be the last person you saw you
would like see them lunge towards you
and that's it you're dead you're dead
you just forget it's like hanging around
a really well-behaved Pit Bull or
something you forget and and also
because it's just so sweet
they're so sweet and there's something
there's something interesting about
being able to be knocked out like to
being able to put yourself in that risk
space you know of like yes because it's
such a defeating thing you know being
knocked out it's everybody's biggest
fear what if I gotten I was unconscious
in front of other like you're at you
have no control over yourself you are
you are
at 11 at a you are limp your limp in
front of the planet yeah ever your your
wife might be in the audience your kids
are in the audience watching daddy your
ego yeah your ego is like what the [__]
the [__] you
you [__]
I told you to use that new synthetic
[__] testosterone the Russians
developed
yeah man I that's like yeah it's you
there's something about you know okay I
don't know if you're familiar are you
familiar with you're probably familiar
with Jack Kerouac the beat poets so I
used to think the B poets is they're
called Kerouac I guess Ginsburg falls
into that category what about uh what's
his name who was all uh
uh
um
was he a beat poet no I think he was at
the same time period but I don't know
for sure I wish I were more literary
than I wasn't really in like the beat
pack beat pack was that Kerouac um you
know uh who else William Burroughs
Burrows that's right kind of gets lumped
in there a little bit Yeah does Ginsburg
Land There was I totally up okay so so
like
I used to think beat meant like
like the Dr the beat of like I don't
know a Congo or some [__] you know they
would all wear turtlenecks and like that
have drum circles or there's this Jazz
but what I read is it means defeated
we're beat we've already been beat we
lost it's over we beat we're not trying
to win anymore and that they're in that
place being beat that's where you find
Freedom that's where you find true
Liberation you've disconnected from the
[__] horrible drums that drive the
ship of capitalism it doesn't mean
you're they're obviously not failing
they're writing beautiful I mean Kerouac
wrote on the road apparently and what
was it one night two nights on speed wow
he took just like in those days I don't
know what kind of speed they had it was
like on paper strips or something so he
just got blasted on speed rights one of
the Great American Road novels in a
couple of nights [__] infuriating man
so it's not like they were like we're
beat taking bong hits doing ketamine
playing God of War it's like yeah
that's the worst experience no but
that's yeah you know what I mean so it's
but but that state of consciousness of
like yeah like I'm already I think we're
another way to put it would be at least
weren't beat in the sense you're not
going to do better than the uni than the
Earth you're not gonna like do it right
there's yeah yeah you're not fighting
this invisible that you're not in this
battle that you cannot really win you're
kind of like accepting that hey this is
where things are you know let me operate
from a place of I am not the king yes
and it's such a wonderful thing to stop
trying to save the [__] planet it's
such a wonderful thing to stop trying to
be because you the ego is so deceptive
that it will convince you that you are
demonstrating some altruistic impulse
yes when really you want to be the
goddamn Messiah you want to be Jesus you
want to like save the you want to be the
only person who saves the planet you
want the credit you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah it's real scary man yeah
I've noticed there were moments like
that I remember a few years ago whenever
I started to get like uh just people
would come out to my shows and stuff I
started thinking oh does God have some
special plan for me
you know like and that was very scary to
me I just didn't know and I was like
what if I'm not doing things right or
like what if I can't handle this type of
if I just had never had like um
you know it's scary when people come to
spend time with you know it's like why
me you know you start asking and then
your ego will start answering sometimes
if you're not [__] you know if you
don't have some inkling or some guidance
or hearing good things from people that
are helping you navigate things
um sure but I remember that I remember
thinking man I
I'm not going to be able to be a leader
you know so this is real scary now I'm
gonna have how do I pretend to be a
leader you know and then that eventually
kind of went away and I realized that
that was a Fool's Gold thing but sure it
was very scary I remember when that
happened I was like [__] like
but to think that yeah like I'm just a
part of this thing and and we've all
we're all defeated how do we operate now
right what now like now and and I'll
tell you man if you look at the like
like the Messiah or God is being like
you look at the messiah's being not a uh
the next Messiah the second coming of
Christ whatever you want to call it the
matreya if you look at it not as being
one person but rather a harmonized uh
group of God knows how many people or
just think about Jesus like
I don't know how many people talk about
like Jesus's like
or think of Mary
who is Mary's great grandfather right
like Mary's great grandfather if Mary
the ver I mean forgive me if this seems
vulgar I don't mean to be offensive but
okay you know what I'll replace Messiahs
think of like the Buddha's great
grandmother like imagine if that great
grandmother decided not to let someone
ejaculate inside of her just the exact
right time and hadn't raised that you
kid in a certain way there would be no
Buddha
so it's like when you start looking at
the fact that like we are all part of
not just like the shitty things the
planet spits out but theoretically you
could be wouldn't you like to be one
pixel
in the the Buddha one pixel one cell one
little tiny part of whatever the next
thing is that like just shakes the
planet to its foundations in the
positive I would yeah that's enough that
would be cool you want to be the whole
[__] thing that's insane that's the
ego it's like you won't you you know
there's a story
ramdas's brother I guess that's great
man that's a great way to say that
that's a great way to say that like how
can I just be a cell in the wellness of
whatever you know so how do I just show
up enough to be a part of things in a
positive way you know and trust that you
are right then you get to have that
thing that your ego is looking for but
in a much more realistic and much more
interactive way like now you you don't
and and you know all the great stories I
mean God look at what Jesus said when he
sent out the disciples I think it was
something something along the lines of
don't worry what you're gonna say I'm
gonna speak through you and if people
don't accept you shake the dust from
your sandals and just that's just leave
no big deal just for you don't have to
worry that's that's what I love about
Christianity is that you don't have to
worry anymore like you're taken care of
now you you don't need to worry you
don't have to uh and so yeah I think
think like you know from that
perspective you don't have to like plan
yeah what the [__] you're gonna do to
become more deep or whatever and have
like a Legions of people worshiping you
as you drive some like whatever the [__]
it is Corvette or whatever probably a
T-Bird maybe yeah yeah you don't have to
yeah that's one cool thing it's nice
about I mean I go to 12 step I go to
recovery programs and so that's one one
of the coolest things I feel is when I'm
in those rooms and it's like people are
listening to each other and everybody's
there for the goodness of one another
yeah there's a feeling I leave out of
there with like man I'm a part of
something that feels good you know and
it doesn't feel like it's about me it
feels like just a part of something that
feels good and I think everybody like I
think there's a general
I think as a society we're like have we
a wonderful look back on our society
like if thousands of years from now
they'll look back and like man what a
wrong turn that we because we're just
this ship in the water that's all
humanity is like and when we took such a
we learned a ton but what a turn that
was going along those ways of of uh
thinking that we had all the answers and
that science was going to lead us to the
to the be all end-all and that we were
going to be able to crack the code like
what a what a exhilarating and
exhausting [__] experiment that was
yeah right let's just you know well I
mean I think the I love the parable of
the prodigal son it's so good for
Humanity it's not just good for an
individual life you know the Prodigal
Son story
synopsis there's a
dad
there's a kid there's a I'm sorry
basically there's two brothers
one of them decides to stay at his
father's house and help with a farm
essentially and the other is like I'm
out of here and leaves and just goes on
this like
hedonistic Voyage Through Life
prostitutes blows all his [__] money
ends up Brad Pitt was it was Brad Pitt
in it it's not a man
it's a parable for the Bible but okay it
would be an amazing Brad Pitt movie a
beautiful man but the the essentially
this kid ruins his life
he becomes some kind of like a pig
farmer which apparently back then was
like the worst thing you could be and so
in shame and humiliation he realizes I'm
gonna have to move back in with my dad
like all the [__] I said about how I was
gonna be a famous break dancer or
whatever [__] he would say it didn't
happen and
[Laughter]
[Applause]
let me tell you this if you're telling
your dad you're going to be a famous
break dancer
nine out of nine times
you're probably not gonna
I don't know the statistics on it but
it's got to be worse than famous
comedian it's got to be much more
improbable so yeah basically the story
is
he he goes back home
and his dad takes one look at him and
he's up he's like legitimately like I
[__] up I let my ego take control I
thought I was gonna be able to do the
caterpillar and moon walk or whatever
the [__] and I suck at dance body rolls
and all that body rolls and what I love
about at least the version of iRead is
before he can finish the apology his
father Embraces him before he can even
finish the apology and says like let's
throw a huge party we're gonna throw
this massive celebration meanwhile the
other brother
is out in the [__] field
and like realizes what's happening he's
like how come you never throw a party
for [__] me I didn't go try to become
a break dancer I didn't buy embarrassing
parachute [__] pants and crypto and
dude start by [__] nftai company or
try to like use that AI to sell my
stickers on [__] Etsy what the [__]
I've been out here with the oxen
what happened well his his father says
um
to the sun like
you know
we're celebrating you've been here
you've been a lot you're alive you've
been here we're celebrating because that
which was dead has come back to life
that's the celebration he my son was
gone lost dead now that now he's back
this is the joy so what you're talking
about with the in any individual life
especially like when you finally get
into a 12-step program you break that
addiction dude and you look at your life
when you were tanking your [__] life
on blow and booze and you look at how
you weren't even there you weren't even
there you were dead you didn't exist if
you look back you're blacking out you
were [__] up you weren't there it was
a way the very best awaking dream and
you can't remember a lot of that [__]
and then suddenly holy [__] you start
coming back to life that's what it's
about for the individual but for what
you're saying is like for Humanity as a
whole
I think that's what's so beautiful about
it is there's the possibility for the
entirety of the species to reorient
itself into another way of being and and
at least because you know it's obvious
in the Bible it's theistic the message
is God doesn't care how much money you
spent on the stupid break dancer clothes
you were wearing or your failed Etsy
business or all the people who you lied
to or all the people you stabbed in the
back as long as those things brought you
back home
that's all that matters as long as
you're able to come and say I'm sorry
and mean it that's what I love about
that story and I think like that's what
Humanity has to look forward to probably
I do I think yeah maybe we did right now
we're like [__] scooping up pig [__]
or whatever and pretending it's gold but
I have a feeling like you know we'll
come back around we'll come back around
yeah if a person can come back around
and all of us can come back yeah because
all we are is just a person really we're
all just one person like you're saying
you're right man just one very complex
very very big person
yeah and you have to I and yeah you have
to start thinking how do we all win as a
speed like how what little part can I do
to help us be a part of that or not even
what can I do but how do I just operate
in a way
that uh
uh but who's everyone and how can I do
that more today yeah that's it that's a
nice question to have each day each day
how can I do that more today for my
fellow man yeah for my fellow specie
member yeah
um it's a good question and sometimes
you will not be able to answer it no
yeah some sometimes you'll go you'll and
you'll you'll slink back off and
but I think having that is like a uh
as a good question is nice and that's a
neat thing about life is sometimes once
certain things get introduced to you you
can't unintroduce them you know yes and
that's one thing that's really cool it's
like man once you kind of see
a little bit of the light you can't
unsee it you know no that's one thing
that's neat about getting into recovery
programs even like you were saying like
you were dead like once you can look
back and see that like oh I wasn't a
contributing member to myself yeah to
anyone I wasn't able to love my sister I
wasn't able to love my brother I wasn't
able to love myself and like how you can
start to you know do those do those
things better yeah man and being a you
know uh the times I've been in those
rooms when you it's what's cool about it
is you see
people who like you thought you hit
bottom like you see people who like
[__] they did the same thing China's
doing right now we're like they're
trying to dig a hole to the Center of
the Earth you're like are you kidding me
what the [__] you know the stories are
crazy but then the fact that you're
looking at them they're healthy they're
they're happy they're doing great that
is where you realize how incredibly
powerful it is to be a human yes because
they sure as [__] shouldn't have climbed
out of that hole yeah some of those
holes man you know what I'm talking
about they're seven yeah they're seven
story holes dude eight stories 12
stories like how did you get a hole this
deep how did you even do it yeah you
didn't even have a shovel like if I told
someone I'm gonna pay you I will pay you
500 000 to destroy your life in this way
they wouldn't be able to do it and these
people did it just with whiskey
yeah like inhalants
it's like it's happening
oh that's [__] cool man
what up what time we had that
um like two hours 20 minutes I'm like
pull under okay
[Music]
um
trying to think of something else I
wanted to think about with you
you were talking about sex in a
graveyard I can actually chime in on
that I worked with a guy at a pizza shop
who uh this is a true story I delivered
pizzas with this guy Steve and he would
take his wife they had kids who they
would hire a sitter every Saturday and
they would go [__] have sex in a
graveyard are you [__] kidding me
yeah yeah his wife's name is Angel she
was 390 pounds what and were they
Mexican because a lot of Mexicans they
weren't no white trash Ohio a lot of
Mexicans go well that's one thing I love
that Mexicans do they do that El Dia de
los Muertos and they go celebrate in the
graveyard with the deceased Mexicans
it's a big part of the culture like yeah
if you're in La you can go on Halloween
to the graveyards and it is like you
know it's like a damn Selena you know
like concert the Hollywood Forever
Cemetery has it's incredible it's
awesome it's beautiful and it's not you
expect it to be like morbid or Grim but
it isn't at all it's celebratory it's
beautiful you can see how they're
honoring these people it's really
incredible yeah I mean can eat an
empanada with a 700 year old Mexican
dude
yeah yes yeah you can
oh yeah The Ramones are buried there
that's right that cemetery is pretty
wild
it is it's and they that's where I don't
know if they do it anymore but
they used to do movies there like on the
weekends I think they still do I
actually went with James Blake he's a
musician he's been on here before he's a
really really amazing British producer
and musician and he um he and I went to
El Dia de los Muertos one time and they
had music and they had yeah just Mexican
families just sitting with their
deceased ancestors yeah you know it's
really sweet I mean it's so so
sophisticated like the way a lot of
people do death is really like [__] up
you try not to think about it you just
try like someone dies and you know you
just try to put them out of there out of
your head I mean and they don't and they
don't really disappear it's funny
because I can think about my father
right and I can think about how he feels
how his I can think about what he wears
I can think about his voice is alive
inside of my head and in my heart I can
feel it I can
um I can put my hand on my heart and
it's his heartbeat like part of my the
beat of my heart was made by two other
people's beats it's a mu it's a [__]
song yeah that's inside of me that was
created by you know so it's really
we really do do that poorly I think in
in uh or I've done that poorly in my
life is honoring
um
the uh the deceased you know honoring
the people that put their time in so I
could exist
you know maybe part of the problem is
it's so bizarre when you lose someone
when you realize somehow even though
their bodies aren't here they're closer
than they've ever been to you like you
have this sense no they're here I mean
not like a ghost paranormal way but like
something deeper than that just like
what you're saying and you don't
you it's hard for people to deal with
that it's almost heartbreaking in a way
or you're afraid to connect with them
you have a sense anytime you do they've
just been waiting for you to reach out
oh that's interesting it's almost
ashamed there's a little bit of Shame if
I were to sit and really just go spend
time like in a room or in an open field
and tell my father I wanted to talk to
him or spend time with him yeah part of
me would feel ashamed that it took me so
long to do it yeah yeah and you know
what I've when I've
like presented that shame to like my
mom's
Soul or whatever you want to call that
the response is always
I love you yeah they don't there's no
like why didn't you [__] use
Ayahuasca to talk to me you you know
it's just a sense of like I love you so
much enjoy your life enjoy your life
you're doing great I love you it's this
place is for love nothing else that's
always been the the the sort of the
message you know
I I it's I they don't seem to even see
shame right on the I think whatever it
is why were you watching Dateline
they're never like that
why why why the [__] were you obsessed
with Keith Morrison
yeah why did you work for a week to try
to do a Keith Morrison impression that
you could never pull off yeah
but what about that avocado
not bad
yeah man it's just yeah it's right why
do you go to that Duran Duran concert
the other night yeah they're not they're
not they just it's like I think whatever
is on the other side as they call it is
so beautiful you know where I'm done
says it's like taking off a shoe that's
too tight it's death death is like
taking off a shoe that's too tiny
whatever's over there is so so beautiful
and so much more real than this place
that
uh
beings that are there
they are they just want us to be happy
they are just love you know and also you
know as a parent like if my kid somehow
reaches through the veil to communicate
with me after I'm dead I'm not gonna be
yeah look at your [__] shitty shirt
why do you have gravy all over here
change your oil
you're not gonna be yelling that
[__] I taught you to do that I tell you
you're gonna burn your engine out it's
easy
I buy you that [__] car The
Inheritance
yeah dude it's like they just love
that's that's it that's it that's a
fundamental fabric of everything is that
kind of energy yeah and you're right the
darkness part is it's like you know
turning on a light you just turn on the
light that's all it is man it's like the
darkness is really the weakest of things
when you consider how it's so you just
flip a light switch light a candle and
it's gone yeah it wasn't really there
and you usually need other people to do
it you need
yeah that's why isolation kills so many
alcoholics and so many addicts that's
why isolation kill creates so many
School shooters and like severe like uh
uh violent nihilists I don't know what
nihilus means yeah yeah nihilism the the
the the the the
idea that all you are is atoms I mean if
you want to take it to the furthest
point it's like this is this is
essentially an accident Big Bang happens
and
just she just by like time and molecules
swirling together
we became what did you call it reactive
we became reactive meat earlier on you
had a really nihilistic description of
human human beings we're just
temporarily sentient we are doomed to
die we didn't ask to be [__] born and
here we are Mortals and a universe of
infinite atoms but whatever we are it's
just a [__] accident like just a a
bad collision between the wrong organic
molecules a long time ago and some
oxygen and some [__] oxygen and [__]
it and then we believe that's true or
not no I don't believe that's true my
experience of life is the opposite of
that
and it's interesting because I feel like
we've created a society kind of in the U
and America where if you're not careful
you can kind of you can get laughed and
believe in that we have a society that
really you know we sat we've created
that a lot of things that mean a lot to
us or that should or really just um
Wares for sale yeah or that um even our
important moments or I don't know I feel
like there's been some deviation but I
think there's like you're saying there's
there's a lot if you cannot see that if
you can find other people
and listen and if you can just
be open to possibility it's you can
quickly get back to a place that feels
good yes
place it feels good
is good right fundamental goodness
there's that's you that's ground level
whatever you want to call it Bedrock
yeah the Bedrock and everything else is
just defense mechanisms and yeah and
yeah exactly you'll know when you're
there because you're already the Paradox
is you're already there and it's just
like that so many comparisons
uh it's like
a lantern that's got a lot of like dirt
or or dust on it you know what I mean
your your soul is
the light the lantern is your countless
incarnations and once you clear away the
dust boom there you are again and that's
the weird I don't know if you had it
with Ayahuasca with DMT that's that
weird familiarity people report which I
certainly experienced where you're like
oh
I know this place
there was nothing to be afraid of this
is just a place of love and joy and
delight and
and [__] I've been so hard on myself
um yeah
oh I was a cockroach for 50 incarnations
okay just like you said earlier what was
I do what was I doing beating myself up
yeah I'm doing great I'm doing great
yeah and and truly if you're a human at
least from the Buddhist perspective
they it's
the Rarity of the human Incarnation from
the Buddhist cosmology like they think
there's more gods and there are humans
that if you are lucky enough to be born
a human you've really you probably
weren't a cockroach like you have done
some heavy lifting to land in the human
realm and especially you know there's a
weird kind of like Multiverse aspect of
Buddhism a lot of people don't know
about but
to be born in a realm where there was a
Buddha where there was a Jesus I mean
you pick your Messiah where because
there's there's the possibility of being
born in a time when nobody
had any kind of spiritual technology
developed so to be in a in a world where
that we have like volumes
volumes of like incredible spiritual
technology that anytime you want you can
connect to is very good karma very good
it's a great point it's very good
fortune
do you think if they if they proved
aliens if there was some proof for them
like and obviously if there was some
further proof that really set in
everybody like everybody it was like
you know
was like wow they're there they're out
there with what would that do to
religion do you think that would
strengthen it or do you think that would
weaken it
well I mean I you know I think it
depends on the religion and the lineage
of the religion I mean if you've been
living in a religion that is doing the
same thing for Humanity that we used to
do for planet Earth the Earth was the
center of the universe so if you've been
living into mindset that humanity is the
you know the sum total of or like the
the final part of God's creation or
something then yeah it's gonna [__] with
your head because now you have to deal
with the fact that no there's the
universe is teeming with life on every
level from the subatomic to the like to
to to to giant planets to God knows what
to the point where we might be some
Atomic portion of something we'll never
understand so yeah but I think you know
a lot of religions already have built in
the idea that we're talking about the
source of all reality a kind of super
intelligent progenitive
uh benevolent Creator force that just
Delights in making stuff and delights
and like sharing
its creation with the things it makes
that we get to co-create with it it
invites us to like sit down at the
potter's wheel with it and make stuff
while we're here so it's a really
wonderful artist whoever it is whatever
it is and it's the best kind of artist
it doesn't like where are the there's no
signatures there's no
copyright there's no IP it's claiming
for the sum total of all things it's
that incredible it's
it's like Banksy
nobody knows who Banksy is it's like
that it's just like here have it all I'm
giving you all of it let's see what you
do with it yeah it's beautiful so I
think from that perspective aliens sure
why not and what if aliens they also had
a God too what if they rolled up with a
couple Gods we did we would figure it
out well yeah that was that's where it
would that's what that's what would be
so exciting it's like what who do they
believe who are you worshiping who is
your god what is an alien god like and
what do they think of our idea of God or
their what if they're like all like
Richard [__] Dawkins and they're
pissed at us like there's no god you
dumb [__] we made you we're your [__]
god look at his big black eyes
emotionless face
we made you you just hallucinated all
the other stuff because we built that
into you it's like believe in a God
because that makes you easy to control
we would beat them up then
we were oh dude I think we would I think
we would fight to have a God the first
alien human world star fight like when a
human finally just punches an alien
it's weird to think our kids might see
that man
it's weird to think that we might see
I don't think there's a lot of beef
between black I have some black friends
and they said there's a lot of beef
between like blacks and Aliens too what
yeah that's like we don't hear about
because we're not you know I guess in
that culture that much but yeah there's
a lot of like
black alien what yeah they don't get
along or they don't
yeah they don't get along that much I
mean how many black dudes you even know
are like yeah who have like alien
posters or anything like that you know I
mean I I honestly I don't know anyone
who has alien posters but like I do know
black people who are like super into
aliens I but maybe maybe I gotta meet
more black folks then you know maybe
yeah who knows it's like I I don't know
I mean I get I know there's a lot of
people who like are think they're demons
I mean that's one of the threads of
of of like that's one of the
explanations for them is it's like no
these are the legions of Satan coming to
the Earth to pose as aliens and trichus
into getting on those [__] ships
don't get on the ships yeah don't get on
the ships because they're gonna fly you
right to Hell [__] don't get on
the ship I'm gonna want to go look at
least on there I bet well yeah of course
me too we will get on the ships but I'm
gonna say hey tell me before y'all leave
no dude you will get on the ship for
sure I guarantee he'll get on the ship I
guarantee it we'll probably be
podcasting on a spaceship at some point
I mean maybe that is lower on here yes
maybe that's a part of it they get you
on the ship they make you forget you're
on a ship they trick you into thinking
you're in the human Dimension we're just
in some Cargo Bay right now
plugged into the Matrix baby
that's awesome man uh Duncan thanks so
much for your time dude anytime Theo Hit
that [__] this is such a so funny yeah
so fun man it's so fun to see you again
and um yeah we should probably just do
one to follow up this one I think people
will love this this has been one of my
favorite chats in a while man dude my
I really think you're wonderful and
thank you so much for having me on your
show it means the world thank you yeah
100 man I want to do it again soon and
uh and we'll do yours yeah we can assume
it from wherever or come back in town
wonderful yeah I'll hit you up
do you ever do them live
um I'm you know I'm building a podcast
studio right now but it's slow going you
can talk to this company here too
they're really good you know I'm I'm
tempted to honestly because I've been
trying to do it at home and I'm just
wondering if that's like a little bit of
like kind of what we were talking about
earlier like you gotta shed that
that skin like why do you want to do it
at home what are you doing like why not
expand do it like you're doing this is
one of the things like you Sakura Rogan
it's like you know you guys are real
Trend Setters you're really leading the
charge as far as like creating your own
TV show basically and like making it
look good having a nice studio and stuff
and I don't know it just takes so much
work yeah well this guy I just I just
started working with this company called
Rooster Teeth and they've been awesome
man it's been good it's been really just
interesting
um and I'm glad that they've been
supportive but yeah it is I think you
know there's something nice about having
it at home it feels homey but I think
you feel homey no matter what no matter
where you would be yeah right you know
sometimes I used to get I started in my
kitchen and I was like oh if I ever
leave my kitchen something will be wrong
I won't be able to communicate correctly
or something
um that's how I feel yeah like I'm gonna
lose like the vibe of like this is my
garage like this is my gritty podcast
Studio oh yeah and it's like that's so
dumb like why do I like I wanna I wanna
expand it just jeez man we need your
voice out there I think thanks man it's
really good to hear I've been really I
feel much better than when I came in
today I feel more inspired
um I feel yeah like I can do better when
I communicate with people
um it's just a really nice reminder uh
you are a nice reminder of how to
operate in the world thank you Theo hey
man we don't have to podcast you can hit
me up anytime you want if you just want
to shoot the [__] I love talking to you
and I would be thrilled so thanks man
thanks man thanks for having me on the
show yeah we'll do it again soon
beautiful Duncan Trussell ladies and
gentlemen
foreign
[Music]
like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone
but when I reach that ground I'll share
this piece of my life I found I can feel
it in my bones
gonna take